just one of them sarah garvey and i am
here with the woman who is blowing up
the manosphere right now all right
pearl um before we even get started
ladies and gents i'm going to do
something
you got a like you got share you got
subscribing if pearl
if they have watched two or more of our
videos
and they haven't subscribed
then we have beef tell them
okay so do that right now today's topic
today's topic is
[Laughter]
should be interesting um you do not get
better than your baby daddy um but
before we get there i'm sure you've got
something to say
okay guys you're ready now second half
of the chat is members only so if you
guys want to become a part of the chat
the second half of the show sign up for
our memberships at the 10 tier there are
two blogs and a discord server as well
so sign up for memberships um on top of
that guys like the video i believe there
are 58 of you in here now so let's get
50 likes come on alike is free don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring the notification bell so your you
are notified every single time that we
go live
so today we got a we got a lit panel
yeah we got a lot of people here today
so why don't we go around everyone say
your name your age your relationship
status and where you're from um terence
i'm from south london
i'm 47 and i'm in a relationship
hi um i'm maxi i'm 32
hi
hi i'm maxi i'm 32 and i'm married and
from north london
hi i'm toyota i'm 31 it's complicated
it's complicated and i'm from essex
i'm gracie baccarate i'm thirty and i'm
single
i'm zakala lingu i'm 27
i am a taken man and i am from croydon
all righty a lit panel so soon as we're
talking about baby daddies and baby
mamas and all this kind of stuff this um
was kind of inspired by a kevin samuels
quote um he actually said um
you don't raise you don't get any higher
than your baby daddy so um our women
having uh
babies for subpar men
okay and then expecting
a less than subpar man to swoop in and
help her out with her subpar baby daddy
and child
it's a bit controversial but we'll start
there the child's not subpar
okay
just saying i'm going no but i think
it's the other way around
i think men
can't get better than their baby mums
most times wow yeah
i think
that the child could become subpar if
the father is in in his life long term
that's if the mom's not a good mother
irrespective
what what what what famous baby daddies
didn't do better than their first baby
mama because i'm thinking of like all
the guys with a bunch of kids like nick
cannon future they're all dating
a new hot 22. i was gonna say
three-year-old yeah i think i think just
because of your age doesn't mean you're
a better woman
just because it well to them it does
that's what i value because men value
fertility i'm pretty certain will smith
could do way better than that
yeah but she's a mad babe that's
different
she's like a five to be honest she's
like absolutely she's just
jada pink is average looking yeah she's
average she was hot when she was yeah
she is yeah but like she's like 45 50.
and she's you think at her age she's
still average looking she looks good for
her age but like if you asked a guy
would he prefer 25 year old version of
her i think most would prefer the 25
year old version yeah that would i think
that's where anyone though so now she's
45 there aren't men lined up to date 45
year olds let's say she's average i feel
i don't think she's average i think i
think you have to
um assess everything in its category i
think for her age she's definitely not a
fighter well the things that men value
are fertility right femininity and youth
she doesn't have youth
she doesn't have youth she's clearly not
feminine
and she's not fertile you also missed
one pearl loyalty
i i have to agree with the um
you can find a better baby mother
because i think there's more good women
than there are good men
hmm so yeah i could agree with that
there are more good women than there are
good men yeah what what makes you say
that and what's your statistical data on
that and what is the version it's not
it's just my opinion it's not statistics
is it is it because of the men you deal
with
um no i'm married so it's not the men i
deal with i'm just curious what like why
is that your opinion on man
um because it's just my opinion i think
there are well for one there's more
women in the world so you're probably
going to find more good women than you
are going to find good men so that's
just it it's like 50 it's pretty close
it's like 55 45 yeah i'm sorry i'm
dealing with statistic people sorry
you encountered more
good women than men but i don't think i
would i wouldn't say that there's more
good women than men
exactly
honestly modern women today by like what
men value it's not like i would say
they're worse than men yeah because the
average age of first marriage is 31 in
the uk so you're taking away the youth
and the fertility
and then um they also value purity so
they're older they're clearly going to
have slept with more people um
interesting
i think as well the fact that you're
married
how long have you been with your partner
for
in in total yeah 16 years 16 years so
first of all you haven't been single for
a while and been in the single game it's
a lot has changed since then okay
um
and i also think that married women just
generally hang around with better people
in general single women
will hang around with other single women
degenerate some some of them you say
degenerate some of them are degenerate
wow
i just don't think that married women
will hang around with a load of single
degenerate women so can i can i ask so
just a question are all married women
better than single women
in my opinion i in my opinion i see them
as more high values no i think you have
more respect for them doesn't mean yeah
i think you have more respect because of
their status they're not necessarily
better women women yeah that's a good
pens
yeah so what's what are we using as
better what's the use i mean like i
think i think they got picked right so i
think when someone has a ring on their
finger like other men acknowledge that
another man vetted her and picked her
so it doesn't necessarily mean every
single one but in by and large in
general like men know how to pick women
and vet women i mean technically jada
pink smith is a married woman yeah i
don't really respect her so exactly so
our women out here just you know because
for me as a man
um when i see who you've had a child
with that says some things to me okay i
agree i agree so i'm gonna look at who
you've bred with who you've chosen to
breed with and if and if i'm thinking of
stepping into that situation what would
be the ramifications for me stepping
into that situation i agree right so
um a lot of women complain about their
quote unquote baby daddies whereas they
are the ones that chose their baby daddy
so as a man i'm looking at you first of
all maybe you don't know how to choose
men and maybe you're bad at choosing and
then so
when a lot of women complain about their
baby fathers it's like well you're
actually complaining about the choice
that you actually made agree
fair point i think i think with
experience
comes like wisdom and i feel like when i
chose my baby father personally
it was i was in a certain mind frame i
was a lot younger i was in a different i
was going through different things and i
think the experience of my baby father
lets me know what i don't want what did
you choose about your baby father
he was a god-fearing person he was a
kind he is a kind person he is
god-fearing and he's a very very hard
worker again it was just we couldn't
make things so he's a good man yeah he's
a good man speaking to the mic so
if he's a good man why why are you not
with him because he's not good for me
why is he not good for you being a good
man doesn't necessarily mean you and i
are compatible why is he not good for
you but he was have different ones but
it was compatible enough to have a child
with he was compatible enough for me to
be sexually attracted to him that's how
you make a child right yeah but i think
right
but
the choice to have the child is yours
yeah
it's not his right no right so i'm
saying that you chose to i chose my
child because i wanted to have my child
yeah yeah i'm saying but you chose it
with him so if he's a i'm just asking
that because i'm just trying to work out
well complicated
it's interesting wouldn't it be within
the best interests for the childhood
like for you to work that out you too
my child's
going to be happy regardless as long as
she has her mom and she as long as she
has her dad doesn't necessarily mean us
together
will give her a happy environment
you put your kid at every statistical
advantage or disadvantage when you don't
have two parents in the home so like
statistically they're more likely to go
to jail they're more likely to fail out
of school
she follows the path of god
so that sounds fantastic but the
statistics don't care about that so can
i just ask but isn't it like like
under the path of god it's like till
death to you part i didn't get married
yeah but you had a kid that's like a
step after which also doesn't follow in
line with like yeah and i deal with it
okay and it's my position sorry can i
just ask do you guys use statistics on
your day-to-day life or is it just
um if yeah if you're having like if
you're trying to have like a
conversation or debate about it okay
okay yeah that's fine you know yeah
if it's debates then it's fine but if
i'm just curious if you guys use it on
yeah i mean i mean like i said though
like pearl was saying like
you put your child at like a
disadvantage if you choose not to have
that child within a family unit right
okay and i mean even specifically um
within like within america i think it's
like 72 percent of even black households
are raised by like a single mum yeah and
then you can you can look at there's a
single parent
to prison pipeline there's that you can
see it you can see that most people in
prison come from
single parent homes okay so yeah i was
going to say in addition to that as well
not only
are the kind of the single parent
household
like levels high in the us but what that
does as well is that actually it
actually like puts us like below the
poverty line so in regards from a
demographic perspective we have the
poorest household households as a single
parent just because of the fact that
there's there's not there's not two
earners in the household so i'll just
say that here that both of us definitely
earned them more than some two-hold
two-parent households so that's why for
me statistics don't work for me because
i do everything against it i definitely
earn more than a two parent household
but that doesn't matter that doesn't
make the rule but i'm just saying
because if someone else came in you'd be
anymore yeah but i might i'm not like my
sole salary yeah is more than the
average
average yeah okay yeah
okay so you earn more than the average
person in the uk yeah right yeah then a
two not one
then two then two people
so you've doubled the average so i have
a question if you guys didn't end up
like getting married again would you
still be okay with the decision to like
leave your baby daddy
yeah yeah you'd be fine yeah i was
married i got divorced okay yeah
you're your ex-husband sorry no no no i
didn't mean to correct you
yeah sorry go on yeah i wouldn't be with
him do you think that finances
will
like essentially like save your kid from
any disadvantage that they'll have
without that
i think she was just tackling your point
of view below the poverty yeah speaking
to them
sorry sorry
i do i do think
i um i'll be in denial if i said that
having two parents in a household
doesn't have a benefit especially for me
i have two boys and i'm a woman and i
act 100 like a woman i can never teach
my son how to be a man
do you understand so i take full
accountability in that area but however
i still felt even though i couldn't
teach my sons how to be men
being around a certain type of man
wasn't good for them
because even
being around certain type of men wasn't
good for them right because there's
certain attributes you pick up and i
don't want my sons to be like that
because i think the way i raise my kids
now i raise them as if the men i want
them to become so even already they're
four and five and i give them certain
responsibilities and they're very
independent already so the delete the
best i can do i will do but i do accept
that i may not do enough for them to
become the men i want obviously i don't
know your past situation yeah so
obviously i don't know why you would say
that it's not right for children to be
around their father i can only assume
that it's
to their detriment i would only assume
that um i think generally um
yeah like you said children need to need
both parents yes i agree and um when it
comes to like baby father baby mother um
just just say uh confrontations um when
it comes to children
um 200 children per day
are removed from
their father's life if i had to call the
family court system okay do you know
what i'm saying and um a lot of the time
it's because women have said certain
things about the father
and now whether they're true or not
we don't know but um
i feel like a lot or i see a lot of
women
in these days and times talking about
their baby father and how bad he is
yet and still you kind of chose you kind
of chose that
so i would never speak bad about the
father of my children to my children or
to anyone right where the public were
here um
whatever was my decision is between me
and him but like for instance did you
decide to leave
yeah right yeah um but
just because because i think i even have
more respect for him because i have kids
with him just to respect my children i
will never disrespect their dad
so if my children say if i was in an
environment where maybe the father of my
child was not there and my kids kept
asking about their dad i would say
something like he's busy at the moment
but when he's available i will he will
be you know he'll come and see you i'll
never say oh your dad he doesn't have
time for you blah blah i will never do
that because it's not for i'm not doing
all of these things for you i'm doing it
for my kids you know i'm the kind of
woman that i will if he doesn't want to
speak to the kids i would call him to
speak to them because whatever issue
we're going through has got nothing to
do with them they didn't come into this
world based on ish problems they came
out of pleasure and love because when
you have sex obviously that's pleasure
right so why would i give them anything
but that i have to give them they have
to be in a pleasurable environment and
they have to feel love
you guys keep talking about you know
choosing the man or you know bad
decisions when you're you know making
children blah blah blah
but you're not acknowledging the fact
that people change as well the person
that you had
the baby with at that time may not be
the same person in two years time
so you have to also acknowledge that as
well it's not that they were a bad
person when i chose to have
this um my baby with them i don't think
i don't think that any of your baby
fathers were bad people yeah so i do
think they were weak that's
did you think they were i do think that
they were weak why we cannot say from a
mentality perspective from a mentality
perspective
it's too there's too much nowadays
around oh god like i can't afford it
like if if i have a kid blah blah blah
whatever
there are a lot of women who step up to
the plate
yeah and decide to have a child my mum
being one of them
and
so like my mum being one of them and my
dad literally he had to work stupid
hours he weren't making that much money
he had to make stupid hours to
to like support me and my mom they ended
up splitting up but it wasn't for
financial reasons it was just just
because of
it's just because of things
however now like back in the day if a
guy knew he was having a kid he'd step
up
we've got uber right most of us have
driving license we can do that on the
weekend plus plus our full-time job
we've got nine months to prepare for
that child
and we've got nine months to prepare for
that child now i don't know what
happened in
in any of your relationships but as soon
as i find out that i've made oh i've
made a girl pregnant or something like
that i'm stepping up yeah it's it's not
it's not even a thing and and that all
comes from a strong mentality
that all comes from a strong mentality
from developing yourself and i know that
i'm quite strong mentally and i think
that people who are quite weak
say nah do you know what like i'm not
like i'm gonna sack this off or don't
even give it a go do you know what i
mean do you think when you say people
change doesn't that kind of sound like
an excuse no no it's realistic reality
it's not an excuse but people used to
change over 50 or marriages and you can
like like it just sounds like
the change is not detrimental exactly
it's not it's not
i'm not saying i disagree or agree with
you but if i think about my situation i
feel like one of the biggest problems us
women have is we date potential
so you see a guy you think oh yeah i
really like him
but when i think about the issues in my
marriage the issues i had in my marriage
also the issues i had in my relationship
they were always there they just became
a lot more heightened when
responsibilities increased so i do think
as a woman i don't feel real i don't
think we realize the power we have on
the path we can have
so i think if we took on that
responsibility i think we will make men
a lot weaker in that element so because
right now it's like men are the prize
men are this men are that but in a way i
feel like they say women are the prize
powers so don't you think men enterprise
then no i'm not this i think both
parties are a prize
in in in their own way yeah but i feel
like
men get more praise now and it's well
now or whenever but i think they get
more praise because
it sounds madder because i want to say
we've allowed them
in a sense of
we've given them that power
if we were to use our brains okay and
me included what do you mean
so me included right i've given people
i've dated the power to have access to
me even though they may not be good for
me if i took it away
you don't have access to me and i feel
like you can be by yourself
yeah but should i be desperate and be
hurt because i don't want to be by
myself
why don't you say on some level you kind
of are what you attract so if you keep
attracting the certain type of guy it
says something
to an extent yes yeah i think i'm saying
it's someone today that when i got
divorced the guys i attracted then to
the guys i attract now are very
different okay right so i do think as
human beings we have to take
responsibility for maybe how we carry
ourselves how we talk all those things
we do
every little thing i would say as well
and i'm just being realistic here so
when you did get divorced you were a lot
younger right yeah and now you are a bit
older the the amount of so so the pool
of the men that you are going to attract
with two boys
it's gonna be a lot less i've never
dated a guy who's got kids i've never
gay the guy who's not wealthy i think
i've even got a better pawn now than i
had when i was younger
what's happening it doesn't count unless
you have a rang like anyone can deal
with a rich guy yeah i would i would i
would only i would date me yeah yeah i
would date you but i would never wife
you
that's your opinion that's fine i'm okay
with that right well but it's like based
on results so like on this show we only
count engagements okay and i can get
like the guy gets on a knee and proposes
to you so for for me especially us being
on our board in the comments we get
i've realized people's opinions don't
matter anymore i think it's what i'm
living that matters so if i say oh i
want to be with a certain type of guy or
i want to do this i want to do that if
i'm not living that i need to sit down
and think about how am i going to
actually get what i want or grace you're
not going to get that because for some
reason it's not working do you give me
that i don't really do
statistics anymore because i feel like
it's not good for me so would you feel
like you
feel like statistics don't
matter to you or something it's nice to
hear that's it
so so i'll say okay so statistically
what do you think that a a divorced
mother of two
um on the dating market right now in her
what 30s i'm 30 yeah right so what do
you think do you think that there are
guys now out there
who are young suitors with a lot of
money thinking that's exactly what i
want i want a divorce mother of two
as my babe as as my next wife
would you say that generally i'll be in
denial if i said yes no i don't think
that's what they're looking for however
my
my life doesn't tell me that it seems
like your suitors are quite decent right
so we're talking no kids wealthy i can't
i can date a guy that's got kids so long
as he's got full responsibility but
that's why i said i also understand why
another guy may not want to date me i'm
acceptant of that now like i'm not in
denial i think oh yeah i can get this i
know it may be harder for me to get that
but i'm okay with that i'm not going to
drive myself crazy and feel like getting
married is the be-all and end-all happy
for me let me let me let me land let me
land yeah so
they they seem like decent suitors like
they've got money and stuff like that
why do you think you haven't been like
you haven't like you haven't been
able to get married
yeah what i
i feel like i've only just grown up
let's be honest i've only just grown up
okay all right so it's more to do with
you i i think okay i think so i've only
just grown up um i've only just realized
what i really want right and
i don't think i was as desirable then as
i am now oh okay
in my mind because men talk about you
know
or you guys or everyone talks about you
know so many girls out there
but if you're looking for quality men in
my opinion there's a certain mind frame
you want the woman to have as well and
there's not that many of them
might happen
i don't know when it comes to the brain
there's a new girl turning 22 every day
yeah
that's fine there's a bad bee down the
road every day yes i'm not disputing
yeah right but i still think they're
some of them their brains are not all
the way up the fact of the the fact that
the fact of the matter is and i love the
fact that you've like fully accepted
this the fact of the matter is is that
i'm going to look at it from my
perspective let's say for example i get
older i've got no kids right and i get
no kids and my wealth goes up
the chances of me the chances of me
wiping up a girl with
two with two kids from like a baby
father that like obviously i don't an
ex-husband yeah an ex-husband or
whatever and stuff like that and
like that's just not a situation i'd
want to put myself in so when you look
at me do i look like i'm a mother or i
look like i've been divorced no so
basically most of the guys i speak to
it's from okay yeah because it's from
what's wrong what makes you think that
you don't like because i don't let
myself go i feel like some of the time
people let them
but here's the thing every kid minuses
you two points so let's let's let's
let's say let's say let's see
let's do it do we look like mothers i'll
just ask you no no i can i can tell
you're mothers okay yeah i don't i'm not
i'm not no no no no no no no no no no no
you don't get offended yeah i'm not
trying to tell her how can you tell you
look like put together her put together
no it's not even saying her yeah
it's not it's not even
so amanda like you can be on like dating
apps and you could look at she's like
yeah she's got a kid like you can tell
sometimes you'll be on you'll be on
dating actually like yeah she's got a
kid can you tell that yeah yeah yeah
yeah like yeah you could i've been there
you can see you're saying it's like a
badge of honor that you look like you
don't have one no because i think i mean
like you're you're like you're wearing
i it the point she was trying to make is
if you look at her and she doesn't look
like a mother if a guy approaches her
yeah it's a genuine conversation
like a mother when you're pushing your
pram down
yeah but i'm saying even as a girl like
if i hear a guy has kids i'm like skirt
so it's like even even if i find him
attractive at first i'm 25. okay yeah
see that that changes everything well it
changes for women um but i'm saying like
like men they can't help they're
biologically predispositioned to not
want to put resources into another guy's
kids like even even in the wild what do
they do when they get the other girl
they kill the cubs
lions literally yeah lions are literally
lions literally do that and look i've
got i've got stepfather like i get it
like i completely understand it i'm just
saying like
don't
like don't be like oh i don't look like
i've got kids you look like you've got
kids like you look you look a little bit
older and it's not and it's not even
it's not even looking at it from that
stuff
you're beautiful you're beautiful women
regardless i don't even know why you'd
you'd like
i don't care that i look like i like i
have a child why would you bring up i
actually didn't i did
they're not all the same
but i already brought it up based on
what you said like for like i said
especially doing our pod and stuff like
that i'm very acceptant of my situation
in the most polite way i don't need you
guys to tell me what i can and cannot
get right because at the end of the day
whether you advise me from today to
tomorrow it's not you i'm going to be
with when it's not you that's going to
get me white when you say what you can
and cannot get what is it that you want
what is it that you want to get could
you just like what is it that you want
to get one thing i do know i want is i
want to be happy and i want to be in a
realistic relationship
but i want to be in a realistic
relationship realistically
and when guys hear that like oh i want
to be happy it's like no yeah it signals
a lack of loyalty to men because it
basically says like you're going to
leave the second you're not happy
so anyone that knows me knows i'm a
writer
in the second no go on you go no i just
because you talk a lot on behalf of men
i was just wondering like
do you have loads of breakfast or
something yeah yeah i have five brothers
okay yeah like there's a certain way in
which men speak and when you say oh i
want to be happy
one it sounds very vague
and two it sounds like
happiness change it changes what people
find what people find makes them happy
today may not be what makes it happen
tomorrow so it's like when you tell me
that's why i said what is it what is it
that you want when you say happiness if
if it's the pursuit of happiness then
you could be pursuing anything and
everything at the same time so if you
have something that you want what is it
that you want i'd like to idea because
it's hard to define happiness but let's
say for example you've got a man
he takes care of you and your kids yeah
this new stepfather you're married to
him yeah he every single night
you get you get your back blown out it's
beautiful and everything yeah food on
the table
food on the table everything it's the
fact you say it's such an english accent
food on the table everything southeast
london accent
is that enough for happiness
no when it comes to women
i mean yeah wow
it's not what more would you need
because women
women's happiness why are we capping
women's happiness changes all the time
right that's why that's why women are
the ones to initiate the majority of
divorces because they think they know
what they want they get the thing that
they want and then all of a sudden they
don't want it so their happiness and
their minds change constantly so like i
said when a man hears our one happiness
it's like well
what today this week this month this
year and then what's your happiness for
next year so i want to be with someone
who i'm compatible with not just for me
but also for him
i want him to see me as someone that
leaves an impact in his life i don't
want it to just be one-sided like if
he's having a bad day i want him to feel
like let me call grace let's you know go
at this are you looking are you actively
looking for that person uh
yeah i'll say yeah now i am and
you haven't found that person so i'll be
honest like i'm really honest if you
notice um i've met guys that tick all
those boxes but i'm not going to be that
woman that's going to be oh yeah he's
hard working he's got good money he's
this he's that and just be with him i
need to feel that strong no i need to
feel i need to desire you
so you're telling me yeah it's going to
be a while
you're telling me all of your boxes can
be ticked and you will still say nah i'm
good no it sounds you're making it sound
crazy
that's how it sounds to me
that's how it sounds because if you if
you ask if you ask men if they'd go on a
second date with a girl that had 80
percent of what she that he wanted
most
yeah yeah most guys answer yes when they
survive even if he's not attracted to
they surveyed if he's not attracted to
her if he had 80 percent of what he
wanted men want attractive women that's
like part of it okay so i'm saying if
you ask women oh does he have does he
have 80 of what you want most girls say
no they wouldn't go on a second
key things
good job money making above average all
of that stuff but i still think there's
something missing but would you okay so
let me ask you something would you like
to be this is how women work off
feelings you know no i think it would
come down to personality
if you take all the boxes but the
personality doesn't matter sorry what's
your name terence i could have like if
if a woman takes all my boxes but she's
a [ __ ] or she's not respectful or if
you've gotten on yeah that's not one of
your boxes though sorry if if she wasn't
yeah
how important is that stuff really
but i'm saying i'm saying like in the
old days they didn't do this and they
had better they were more successful if
you look at more traditional countries
where they actually arrange marriages
like they're not talking about
personality and like vibes and that sort
of thing and they have better results
yeah i get it but i'm looking for
compatibility i'm looking for i'm i'm
looking for companionship so we need to
finally
i'll have to disagree disagree a little
bit with that one because like let's be
serious like if you marry a psycho like
that but that's that's an extreme yeah
right
i'm right okay don't marry a psychopath
but typically when you get the families
together and they meet each other you
can vet that out right yeah but i'm
saying they weren't in the old days like
talking about compatibility the way we
do nowadays like a prime example
actually a modern day now like for me in
particular for what i want i couldn't
even deal with that i couldn't deal with
a girl who wants to work full-time never
want to take care of the kids bed like a
lot of girls don't even want kids
anymore like it's like
and that's very very common so
i understand when you said that's an
extreme like but for me like actually it
isn't really an extreme like if a girl
wants to work full-time right and
and only went full time she's like oh i
don't not really bothered about kids
which actually a lot of young girls are
aren't really bothered about kids
anymore
that's what that's a massive red flag
for me and i wouldn't even go there so
that's different different goals and
like timelines you don't think that's
different than the way your
personalities mesh
because to me that's a difference in
values like you're talking about a
different thing
i don't think that young young women
aren't interested in having children i
just think they're not interested in
having children young
are
childless females are childless
oh oh it's
half of women half of women at 30 are
single and childless
and that number's rising and rising and
by the way women have body clocks like
it's not that right okay but there's ivf
like there's a lot of technology now
that men don't mind ivf's really
if you get ivf it's twenty five thousand
dollars per kid and you don't even know
if it'll work okay but some people can't
take that race right but like it's not
the majority of women because the
majority of women make 35 000 dollars in
the u.s per year which i don't know what
the conversion is here right but i'm
saying like like that's a luxury
lifestyle people are promoting to
average women like the majority women
own two-thirds of the world's debt even
though they make less money we're not
good at
savings typically yeah yeah so where's
your where's your head at right now
you're 25 like what's what is it for you
you're you don't have no kids you're
you're tall you're beautiful like you're
a desired woman right now you're at your
peak so where's your head at i want to
get married like sooner rather than
later are you dating now i am how are
you finding it it's cool yeah i mean no
i'm just i'm not trying to cheat he's
intentional is he intentional with you
has it made has he made it clear oh no
sorry i don't have a boyfriend i thought
you meant are you like looking
are you looking no no no no boyfriend no
boyfriend i'm just asking about you i'm
not trying to what age do you want to
have children by
um i'd like to have my first kid before
i'm 30. okay okay that's good yeah do
you sorry to switch guys but do you
think there's like a baby mama baby baby
father culture
that we find is just okay
i think there was around our age group
but i think the new age group i don't
think so i think they're so intentional
of not getting having kids quickly i
think my age group when we were younger
it was like yeah having a kid wasn't a
big deal do you think
that a daughter seeing a single mother
raising
her
is likely to get married and do all that
so what because the statistics actually
show that a daughter who's raised by a
single mother believes that oh it's fine
i can do it on my own just like my
mother i'd agree i was my mom's a single
mother but my dad
my dad actually passed away so she
wasn't a single mother by choice so i
feel like she never raised me like oh
life is going to be okay if you do not
have a man right however i did
i did have a child out of wedlock as you
made clear and
i raised my child to know well my
daughter's only two but i do let it be
known that i still want a husband i
still do want to get married so
so for me do you think a lot of the but
i do think like a lot of the
the reason for the culture of baby
mother baby baby father is because
people are not planning children no i i
think what the issue is
is our parents and i don't i'm not
blaming our parents
i'm saying what you see is what you
ingest so for instance a lot of us women
are not as desirable or i think someone
spoke about being feminine right because
especially as like us women
who have had like my mom is married now
but she was single
like most of the time when we were
growing up and i feel i see my mum
working hard making decisions
i then get into a relationship and i'm
doing the same thing you can't do that
you have to learn how to
communicate with a man or be submissive
and all of that kind of stuff but i
haven't learnt that because i haven't
seen it i've had to learn that from
talking to people reading stuff the
internet all of these stuff and i think
that's why a lot of us are single
parents
do you feel that
i disagree with grace because i'm
somebody who has been raised by a single
mom my mom's never been married after my
dad passed away and he passed away when
i was six and i know that i have to be
independent because i have to be
not because i genuinely want to be when
i've been in a relationship i am i'm
naturally submissive i'm naturally
maternal i'm naturally somebody where
did you learn that from but i didn't i
didn't learn it for my mom you
subconscious is that exactly what i mean
i did it would you would you would you
access what i saw
would you would you guys axes describe
you a submissive
do you believe that you should be
submissive to all the menu days no
i don't think circumstances make you
something i feel like if a woman is put
in an environment where she feels like
correct me if i'm wrong but if a woman
is put in an environment where she feels
safe where she feels she's allowed to be
a woman and she's in an environment
where there's respect to both ways
subconsciously if she's not crazy she'll
be submissive
do you think men get i think i think
you're either submissive or you're not
i don't i don't really think you can
pick and choose
i don't i don't i don't i don't think
you can really i don't think you can
pick and choose when you're submissive
that's like men that's like men saying i
pick and choose when i'm going to be
masculine so that's like sarah wearing a
dress and coming in and thinking what up
what happened
if you don't respect your partner it's
different from being
from not being submissive i'm naturally
a submissive person however i can be put
in situations where i'm arguing with him
and i can be disrespectful
that doesn't mean i'm not submissive i
think so why would you want to
disrespect someone like that you can
disrespect someone in any situation
mm-hmm like can i just say
i feel like submission
you need to respect in order to submit
fully not all the time i do well there
can be aspects of submission where you
don't need to respect them it can
literally just be
yes sir that doesn't mean you respect
them
you're outward behavior i mean like you
might not respect them in your mind but
if you're submissive your your behavior
will show that doesn't mean not having a
voice i didn't say that i'm just saying
you're outward because you just said oh
you can just say yes and not respect but
you can be disrespectful at the point
you're being disrespectful you're not
being submissive can i can i have an
example
can i have an example of how like you
guys are submissive in your day-to-day
life
well i thought you said you said
complicated what no you're saying your
day-to-day life yeah because you're not
your relationship yeah yeah yeah so yeah
because you were saying you could be
submissive in the realm so first of all
you clarify to us sorry can you clarify
to us what you deem as submission well
submission basically is follower it's
like you are you're following leadership
um
sorry but i follow leadership at work
no that's a good example yeah that's a
good example i am a supporter i i
actually work in as part of my program i
actually support the program so
that's my day-to-day
um
honestly
i feel like submission should be both
ways in a marriage okay um and that is
that can be done differently though
um i feel like for example
my husband
may be submissive in a sense where
any decision that he chooses to make he
can he we talk about it first it's not a
thing where oh it's my house it's my i
pay for it i think and i'm gonna do it
the question is when you guys disagree
where how who makes the decision because
at some point you guys are gonna
disagree who makes the decision i he
makes the decision yeah so you have to
get the last word yeah so
so you are submissive to him then yeah
yeah i never said i wasn't that's why
she's married
wow that's why that's not that's not why
but yeah
okay well you disagreed with that one
it's hard you know because i know like
pearl mentioned she was like oh like
i i just think it's a thing that you are
and you can't choose but
the state of some men nowadays who can't
make a decision to take a go out on a
date like oh where do you want to go
blah blah blah like like it is that bad
like it's it's that bad out there like
certain man can't can't can't play
so you know how you said that um you
feel like submission is something you
just have or not right you said that um
i i don't believe that you know i don't
and the reason why i don't believe that
is because i know how i am now and how i
wasn't before
and i was nowhere near submissive but i
think it was because of the situation i
was in maybe it was in me and i didn't
know
that i could i can't argue with that do
you think you're confrontational
maybe because we're on the pod you're
thinking that but on a normal day i'm
chilled
on a normal day i'm trying i don't
believe you i don't i don't believe i
don't believe so i generally i i do
agree with you i don't believe that if
the right guy came along and said look
like first date i want you wearing this
i want you here at that time you're
gonna you're gonna kick off i think that
would be me i can't even
yeah exactly i don't think you're going
to start kicking off being like no
actually i'm just curious independent
woman like no you wouldn't you wouldn't
you'd be like okay yeah no i'd do it
yeah a man that talks to you like that
doesn't respect you and therefore
doesn't submit
that
he doesn't respect you no if you're
looking at oh this is what you're going
to wear no no no no no no no no right
but not in that way
wait so he's nice enough to take you on
a date and you're mad about the way that
he took you on a date no but you're
going
like whoa wait that's what i love
it's nice i'm saying it's nice just
because you
so i'm saying if he's nice enough to
take you on a date
like why why are you complaining about
him telling you what time to come and no
no no and what to wear no you can't tell
you can tell me what time to come it's a
date at the end of the day i know but if
he says what to wear like i like the way
you tell me that's what i said it's not
it's not you if that's why i said
oh this is what you're going to wear you
can't talk to me like that i think
you're
but you realize that that's really
confusing for men because like like we
pick up on things that men don't like
tone of voice and like eye contact and
like smaller things so when you say oh
you can't talk to me that way and you're
saying the same thing but it's how you
say it like to men that's very confusing
well if it's confusing then i'm sorry
you need to go back to school
because everybody knows you're the way
you talk to somebody can have a
different result you can get it no i
think it just came out aggressive i
don't think that was his intention his
intention was i'm taking charge we're
going here that's what i want you to
wear um this is what time i want you to
be ready but not in not in a controller
yeah
in a in a
uh do you go try it no what way
like acting in good faith with someone
not like immediately just jumping that
oh he's trying to control you i didn't
say he's trying that's not that's not
what i think he just came out aggressive
but i don't i'm just saying how you say
something for example it's not saying
i'm not saying you can't tell me oh can
you wear something like this or this is
a time we have to meet
as i said everything is how you talk to
somebody because remember this is a
first date so how you talk to me i'm
going to be picking up on that as well
so that's what i'm not saying it's going
to be controlling if you the way you say
it may come across controlling that's
why you have to be careful when you're
talking to people first impressions
matter and that's just if that's
confusing for you then sorry i mean if
you don't like it then you don't have to
turn up in the game no
no no no no this is what i'm saying and
this is why marriages don't work oh if
you don't like it then you can no you
can have a conversation with somebody
and be like oh do you know what could
that be you don't know me you don't know
that i don't like it so i'm gonna give
you a chance to get to know me and i'll
explain to you what i like and what i
don't like it's not about oh i don't
like it i'm not going on the date no
i'll still go but we'll have a
conversation and i'll just let you know
okay this is what i like and
don't tell me to what to wear and stuff
like well well i didn't even tell you
i'll deliver it how i'm going to deliver
it yeah i think you might have
misinterpreted that kind of what i said
the reason why i say i'm going to tell
you what to wear is because most of the
time i'm not going to tell you where i'm
going to go where we're going to go
okay
sorry i didn't interrupt you though
somebody else did but we just that's
fine okay i'm gonna read super chats for
a second guys you already know what we
are saving for okay
get
ish a camera let's go you wanna know
what ish looks like
send a super chat all super chats will
be read
for the most part um
so and to start we got a hundred dollar
super chat let's go
okay thank chris thank you to the ladies
on the couch you help keep other women
delusional and remain as side chicks to
guys like me you are my virtual wing
woman i could not live the lifestyle
without other women co-signing the lies
i tell them don't back down i need you
sorry
okay kane kane marco modern women can't
stand facts and statistics their concern
is fleeting happiness the sisterhood and
fairy tales the things that men want
actually want from them flies right over
their heads sentience what rubbish when
women ask how's your dating life
question it's not a genuine question
especially in a debate it's a it's used
to bring awareness and shame to someone
other than the one who asked the
question bad faith alistar horton sadly
happiness is nothing more than dopamine
high and like any drug is addictive you
don't let your emotions control you
sentience oh sarah is back the real
pearl is finally back i am working but
looking forward to calling out the
bullocks as it comes out like the
disingenuous guy with weak arguments
next to the other pearl swoosh baseball
addict to the dummy in green you can't
be a rider and leave a rider is defined
by staying stop the cap also you're a
baby mama two kids no husband um dequarn
dating a rich guy but no ring she's a
side chick without knowing it the uk
economist what would an affluent man
pass his wealth to another bloodline
why should he give another man's kids
his success and wealth adam strong
responsible cords is
strong responsible cords in a man don't
change with time unless you're weak you
chose a weak man you rushed an important
decision with your emotions
these are the results mgtow by logic
when a man woman says people change what
it actually means is i along with other
women don't have actual core values will
adjust as needed the uk economist
remember women only attract certain
types of men they qualify for your
guests most likely did not qualify for a
high quality gentleman who could be a
fantastic husband and father pearl i
keep getting um started on supporting my
future baby mama you go ahead and flex
on your panel uh because i am a few a
six-figure black man with a job in stem
no jump shot now get my stepson ish a
camera
is that it yeah that's it
um
all right
we have
substituted we've switched
and it's the hottest day of the year
okay so hottest day of the year folks
okay so you might see people like
fanning
and like trying to like stay here
they don't have air conditioning here
guys no air conditioning here
so um yeah when you see our shiny faces
and our sweaty faces just know that it's
it's the hottest day of the year right
now so that's why you can see us like
this we're just we're just switching it
up
we are just getting some new panel
members in and switching out the old
ones with the
ish then the man that needs us on camera
he's actually doing it doing it for us
so um okay
um also we're turning on members only
now so if you guys want to be a part of
the chat sign up for our memberships um
if you have a comment you want read
super chat it and we'll read it um also
we have a new facebook page and a twitch
page so go follow that it should be in
the description and if you want to come
on the show dm eddie if you're in london
his instagram is in the description
nice
okay when it comes to
baby daddies and baby mamas do baby
daddies
get the same stigma
that baby mamas do
single mothers
i don't think we get the same stigma
because i think statistically if a child
is raised in a single father household
they actually do better surprisingly
enough i think when i first heard that i
was like shocked by that i think there's
reasons for it i think in general not
always like this is a general rule our
temperaments are the same throughout the
throughout the year so we don't have
obviously the time of the month or
anything so i think we can be consistent
whereby if obviously if a child is
raised in with a single parent a single
mom household obviously there's
different times whereby if she's going
through a menstrual cycle
her mood may change and that could
affect the child as well so like a
chauvinist yeah yeah i am i do believe
in the patriarchy
you sound like a misogynist
um do baby fathers get the same stigma
i think that's a bit of a silly comment
to be honest with you to say that
children are impacted by the menstrual
cycle of their mother no
they are we're chemically different
every single day it's confusing for
child that's why men are um fathers
statistically are better like raising
kids after the age of eight because it's
confusing but to use that as a measure
of like how
well a parent
parents
it's not so i'm not i'm not putting
criticism on the mom it's just how how
it
is different yeah for example i've
always said men tend to go with their
intellect where women tend to go with
their intuition that's our difference
it's not a criticism that's the way
we're built yeah
yeah i can't dispute that obviously
there is a difference
it's the same reason like women have the
majority of the debt is because we're
more influenced by like emotion and like
ad campaigns are typically targeted
towards women
but are are we are we like looking at
that as
as an effective parent i was just
well no i'm saying i'm saying it's the
same like the same reason it's because
we're more governed by emotions it's the
same reason like men or kids tend to do
better with single fathers over single
mothers
over the age of eight okay yeah hence
why the two-parent household is the best
solution is the best solution 100
i would have to agree
you would have to agree with me
with that i well i agree that um
you know with what this gentleman here
is saying that you know it makes sense
well i agree with the statistics it does
actually make sense i haven't read the
statistics but it does make sense
because as you said women are governed
by our emotions this is why
two-parent household is necessary men
and women we're not the same
it creates a balance yeah and we need
each other exactly interdependent
exactly so for me i have two nieces and
a nephew and i look after them sometimes
and i feel like
when i see the mom involved in the farm
involved my brother there's more of a
disciplinary
um energy that my brother holds that
he'll be able to come in and be more bit
structured and you know i guess govern a
situation in a different way not to say
it's better
but in a different way and when those
two solutions and those two different
perspectives come together
it works it's you know it's the way the
most i intended it to be so yeah
and plus remember back in the old days
what would mothers always say to their
children wait to your father yes
yeah yeah and i agree i'd have to agree
yeah so i have a question do you guys
like when at what point
should mothers put their happiness above
their kids
because we know that single
parent households like kids are at a
disadvantage right
so for me like i don't think there's
really a good reason to break up a home
outside of like extreme cheating abuse
like like the extreme scenarios because
i feel like as a mother you should want
to put your kids happiness above your
own yeah
i agree i think um
i think at no point sorry
um i think once you have children you
have to understand that it's no longer
about you
you have to become selfless and um yeah
your children are paramount
how realistic is that in these days and
times are um
um i don't know
i don't know i just i just think you
feel like women are taking put in their
happiness before their children
definitely and most definitely i think
most definitely i think a lot of women
nowadays if you want to say modern day
women they're very materialistic you
know very very materialistic it's like
what you said we're more likely to be in
debt and things like that yes i guess
we'll want to go
get our nails done get our hair done
stuff like that you know the vanity
aspect of things whereas um men
primarily wouldn't be doing that yeah
you know going back to what you said as
well a man would be more like okay i'm
going to work my children need to be
taken care of is there dinner on the
table that type of thing but um with
women
it's a bit different and i don't want to
sound like what do people say pick me
and stuff like that oh you sounded like
a picture
but you know what honestly this is no
but this is this is my standpoint you
know i come from a single parent
household i grew up with my dad product
like for majority of the time but it got
to a point where my dad wasn't involved
and i saw the way my mom has been
throughout all of that because um one of
the ladies was saying it before um i
remember who was saying it but
there's a certain type of closure that
comes with when a father passes away and
a woman understands like maybe what her
place was in that dynamic and the father
passes away but when there's like
infidelity etc etc and the father is
kicked out it's a different type of
dynamic so um
for me the way my mom's always been
she's been very selfless she's always
put myself and my brother first
and i feel like that's built certain
levels and certain principles and values
within us that do come from scripture do
you come from the most high but i feel
like
yeah sorry i lost my train of thought
but i just i feel
like i feel like women
have a lot to assess in the same age
it's not just entirely because of women
society as a whole has a lot to answer
for but we do need to do a lot of you
know reflection on what our
goals are and you know as you said women
aren't really willing to have children
so that just shows you right off the bat
women aren't trying to put children
before themselves because they know once
they have children i think it's a i
think this
the society we live in is quite
it's quite anti-life mm-hmm i agree i
think it's quite anti-life especially
when it comes to
um the importance of children like we've
just had you know in america the road
versus great case and people have gone
crazy about it and it's like people are
now arguing
whether or not life should exist and i
think that it's actually i think that's
actually
it speaks to society in which we live in
like with that this is an anti-life
society you know what i think about a
lot if it was a dog that they were
pulling off the limbs one by one
crushing the soul
and skull and sucking it out of the womb
like people would have a different
opinion it's crazy but it's weird
because when it's like an actual kid
they don't care yeah yeah i think the
type of comments because i saw a few
things online and then people going up
to people asking what are your views and
the type of comments that i saw women
making i'm just like wow is this how far
gone we've like how far gone we're in
society yeah i mean i'm not
i mean your your perspective and your
opinions your own but
celebrating it
exactly we need something else
well and they even um like i was doing
interviews the other day and someone was
like oh you're brainwashed because
you're american i'm like why is it when
a girl has an opinion that's not the
same as most women where i'm
automatically brainwashed like i can't
as a woman i think for myself or
you're supposed to go down the liberal i
guess left leaning as a woman
yeah if you're a conservative woman then
yeah you're brainwashed and you're a
pick me
get to the point like you know you're
having a conversation like what is a
woman now like you don't want to have
kids but what is a woman like you see
that now as well you know
that commentary that comes from that
side of l so how much degeneration can
you push in society before people go now
i've had enough yeah i remember i saw a
meme the other day and it has a picture
of wonder woman and the debate whether a
woman so the first name was in 1960 this
was wonder woman now what is a woman
it's true
i think it's kind of like a good thing
though that we are kind of moving away
from this representation of what a woman
should and shouldn't be
and we're now kind of in this era where
all of those rules about being a woman
and what it is to be a woman even
choosing themselves over their own
children i think is something that is
completely changing what it means to be
a to to be and stand as a woman in this
society i think you make up you make a
good point there but don't you feel that
being a woman is something innate let me
give you an example in the animal
kingdom i don't think there's a debate
the lioness does muscle the hunting
because it's innate in her and it's the
pride it's the male lion that obviously
protects the pride and stuff we don't
say
or the animal kingdom societies is told
the lioness to be the primary hunter we
just say it's innate in her of course
but i think above
but i think above all of that
instinctual behavior the thing that
throws us apart from lions as humans is
that we have fought
yeah but you can't undo our you can't
undo our biology is the thing and i
think it's not
women can have the choice right they can
have the choice to do whatever they want
i support that but a lot of times we lie
to women and say they're going to be
happy when the least happy group of
women is 45 single and childless i think
we're lying i think we lie to people in
terms of what happiness even really is
and what it should feel i feel that you
know in society we're told that
happiness is this continuous state of
euphoria to some people we don't really
argue the fact that we're all trying to
achieve this certain state and
life but actually that state of life is
just completely misrepresented and
unrealistic yeah i think the word we
should be using is self-happiness so i
remember when the other girls were here
they're looking i need to be happy i
think the word that you need to say is
fulfillment or joy because happiness i
can take an extra pill and be happy
yeah definitely fulfillment joy
and i think purpose as well and i think
where we ask this question about well
should we even
should we even
like why is even life even existed well
it's i think what will you my comment
you made earlier about life what about
being anti-life yeah being anti-life but
in a way it's like okay well
you know we're
with all this purpose we want to have
that we all are seeking meaning within
what is we're trying to do yeah but what
could be more meaningful than a child in
life i i think like the most basic
the most basic like tenant of survival
is life must continue yeah like
everybody knows that if we don't let
life continue then we have no survival
because even even me like i have a
career let's say i hit a million subs or
10 million subs let's say this gets
really huge it means nothing if i don't
have a kid 65 like you're gonna be 65
and alone and happy at christmas but
what's the message you're trying to put
out there to people what do you mean so
like you're saying you could have a
million subs and then even then if you
then if you don't have a child then then
it kind of means nothing but then
without that child there
but you're still doing something so
without the child though yeah without
even having a child by you creating a
platform with a million subscribers for
example and actually putting these
conversations out well my message is
that feminism lies to women and they
tell you to prioritize your career above
all else when families what's the most
important thing and if women are free to
choose what they want to choose do what
you want to do
but
it's dishonest to say you're going to be
happy if you chase the bag the thing is
women actually know this and they deny
it to themselves you know i mean like
women know that they are the most
fulfilled
when they are pursuing that
life of a husband or even it's not a
husband even a partner and a child and
that family life and i think women have
now been
convinced oh no you know what that's not
what it is chase the bag and it's like
well the people that are chasing the bag
are the most unhappy you know what i i
agree and i disagree because
as tiffany said and someone else said it
as well like you can
be happy and fulfilled with your career
and things like that and some people are
just naturally nurturing and maternal
and some people actually aren't
when you're naturally maternal and
nurturing you want that you crave that
but there's some women out there who
actually aren't yeah even if they sorry
to cut you but even if they have a child
then it's like what do they say some
every child deserves a parent but not
every parent deserves a child so um i
think
yeah that's where my mind says i think
sometimes what feminism sometimes says
you can have it all but they say the lie
is you can have it all at the same time
i think what the doctrine should be you
can have it all by different times so
for example when you're young i think a
woman's priority is to raise her family
once the children are old then pursue
the career so you have the best of both
worlds but i think
when it comes to like the whole baby
daddy and baby mother situation is that
women have
children
and then
after having the children they want to
try and do the whole hot girl summer
thing
you know i mean it's like let's do it
after i've had children it's like well
you know sometimes you kind of chose
your blame there that's like sometimes
how weird is it when i see girls like
they'll come on the show they'll have
kids and i look at their instagram it's
like their ass is all over instagram i'm
like i will be mortified if i was a kid
and my mom ever put something like that
on the internet
like and i and i think about this and i
don't have kids like when i post [ __ ]
i'm like i want to have kids someday i
can't have anything like weird that i
don't want them to see i guess it's kind
of telling of the society that we live
in as well because you know a lot of
women the majority of women they're
looking at this standard of like you
know the superstars the you know i don't
want to put names out there but you know
who i'm talking about all those people
out there they've had their children and
they're still out here on
the swimsuits etc etc i'm not here to
judge anyone i know where my standard of
life is it comes from the most like it
comes from scripture that's my standard
jonathan and i think that standard is
conducive to life it's like we said
earlier anti-life and i think because
women see that
they just they want that they and
they're not thinking okay what's best
for me what
i don't know i kind of haven't unlocked
that but i think that's what the
standard in society is that's what
society is selling women nowadays and
they're falling into that do any women
here today have kids currently on the
panel i don't okay since i've missed the
mothers can i just say something i know
it's the hottest day of the year but i'm
hot because i've had so much stuff this
evening that i disagree with i'm so hot
but it seems i'm not gonna get the the
direct
retort i was that you were hoping so i
just want to make it clear right now
yeah yeah don't worry don't get better
than your baby no just because this is
you don't get better than your baby
father nine times out of ten yeah you
don't yeah and negative personal
experience from the general rule does
not prove anything yeah to earn i know
this doesn't refer to youtube but i just
need to get this off my chest because i
feel like some viewers are like there's
no one going to address this like
to earn to
my humble opinion
to earn twice as much as the average
male yeah is extremely extraordinary
here and if you're some and for somebody
to be in such an extraordinary
circumstance yeah
yeah they have to have a level of
respect for that and not make it sound
like it's just average joel stuff
because in a day you the fact that
you're in such an extraordinary
personal circumstance doesn't disprove
the rule it doesn't disprove the
argument really it doesn't okay good
question just to fraud
to the sisters here
do you think that um because think it's
it's very easy to say why can't you be a
wife one of the things that kevin
samuels was always saying who taught you
to be a wife
but then again we don't have families or
institutions that can teach young women
to be a yfgc so is it i think it's a bit
harsh to expect that to happen in the
21st century so let's face it especially
what gets pumped up in the media or in
what we watch that will influence you
but wasn't that sorry traditionally from
the mother or the grandmother to pass
that yeah but we don't have that these
days we have broken families now so in
that sense not all families are broken
right so there has to be somewhere in
the family where that can happen i think
in the western
context as like i said the poorest
demographic is obviously uh the black
community not to say that what's the
hesitation for so
long to say it's a lot like you like you
was weighing it up like who might it be
roll it off the tongue
okay
but i'm just saying though that um like
for when we had the um
three ladies here and obviously they
were saying that they're single moms and
stuff like that
the argument is okay
did what example did they see about a
consecutive like nuclear family and
stuff like that and it's hard not a
feminine one well i said the baby mama
culture has has taken over whether it be
in the house whether it be in the media
and the thing is there's no shame
anymore that's not that's the other
thing like every bad decision a girl
makes she's bailed out of thank you
every every single one and it's really
frustrating because if if a girl gets
pregnant right she she can get bailed
out by an abortion or she can become a
single mom and then get money from the
government or her baby daddy and who
pays for both of those things it's men
men are feeding into all the systems
that bail us out i think sorry to jump
in but um i think
i don't want to put all the blame on
women but i do believe that women have
more power than we actually realize
because even back in the day like i'm
reading um the iliad right now and um a
lot of wars were started because of
women read the odds i think women
realize it to be honest
yeah that's the next book lined up but i
just feel like women aren't realizing
the amount of power that they have
as you said there's a lot of crutches
that we have in society that are making
us feel like we have this power but i
feel like it's a bit on um
i think i think there's a select i think
there's just as we have a upper select
portion of men who might be seen as
pre-select or you know upper echelon
yeah yeah no i'm i agree i feel like
there's a portion of men who maybe don't
relate to that top tier
who are well aware of the fact that a
lot of women are well aware of the power
that they hold i think some aren't
though i think you know ignorance is
bliss
i mean ignorance is bliss but i think
there's actual ignorance as well like
so what kind of power do you mean
um
we have the power to
you know
inspire men
to carry ourselves in the way that
you know not all of them but we'll
encourage them to treat us in a
different way and i think if women band
together and actually started to maybe
carry ourselves in more of a more this
way
as i said i'm probably opinion i'm
probably gonna have a lot of that here
but i feel like we start to carry
ourselves in a certain way then
you know
i don't wanna say schooling guys but
just carrying ourselves in a certain way
well but i think the problem is after
birth control you can't go back because
there's always gonna be a girl that puts
her tits out to to get to get something
like whether it's only fans whether it's
just being like the side chick whether
it's because the problem is after birth
control it gave us the ability to
basically girls that are fours fives and
sixes to sleep with the eights nines and
ten so everyone's screwing the same 20
10 15 of guys
and the issue is like after birth
control like you can't go back
but i think that's i think we've just
entered a realm where women are given
more choice but i think they don't they
don't realize the power of the choices
that they make behind them because they
still
we're because we because we've been
conditioned in such a way that we're
most women not most men but some women
feel
they they feel fall into that category
feeling victimized well it's because
women like to be victims yeah and i
think that's and i think i think a lot
of people like to be victims because i
think most people don't like taking
responsibility for themselves but look
at it like this
but the thing is the thing is men aren't
bailed out women are always bailed out
of a bad decision they're homeless
there's women's shelters there's no
men's shelter it's not not
by and large
every bad decision a woman makes she's
bailed out of in some way or another
most of the time no a man it's not the
same
is it not no
definitely like the thing is the thing
is reality hits men hard so for example
if a girl gets fat right we have body
positivity there's no body positivity
for men they don't give a [ __ ] thank you
there's no
like like and
and if um if a girl gets like sleeps
with a ton of people there's [ __ ]
shaming and so like they take away the
things that men care about yeah but they
don't do that to women
like like even so if we if we get fat
we're bailed out of that decision
because there's body positivity if we
sleep around we're bailed out we're
bailed out of that decision so if we if
we decide to be [ __ ] we're bailed out
because there's birth control if that
fails we're bailed out because of
abortion if that fails and you keep the
kid and you're homeless you're bailed
out because there's women in children's
centers if if that doesn't work there's
some government program and here i'm not
i'm not sure what it is but there's
always some government program paying
out single mothers so it's like whatever
we do we're bailed out
you know who has that
and you know who has that many bailouts
or that many um back doors that they can
actually go through do you know the only
other group of people that have that
many back doors children oh
true just saying yeah question
do you think women have too many choices
yeah do you think two main choices is
about
i think that we all have choices that we
are
unaware of um
but do you think too many choices is
actually a bad thing because i actually
agree even for but this is not just for
women this is foreign i think so because
we don't understand that there's
consequences
right
well that's the whole thing about the
whole baby daddy baby mama culture like
that whole oh what are the consequences
of me doing this i've always said to
people
anyone can have sex with any anyone they
want to i'm not going to tell people not
to have sex but
have it in a way where you're not
creating a generation of children right
that are going to be
you know and the narrative is that
there's a bunch of deadbeat dads that
aren't taking care of their kids and
that oh she just got finessed or she
just you know fell in love like and even
even when i i bring like baby mothers on
here it's always the guy it's never
anything with them or i picked wrong
there's no accountability for their
actions it's always i picked wrong
therefore putting it on the guy and i'd
like to hear i said i'd like to hear the
guy's version yeah there's a lot because
baby mothers say a lot they say oh my
baby daddy's this he's that and i'm not
toxic yeah i wonder what the guys would
be saying about you know i mean like
what would guys like how would they talk
to talk about you as a co-parent how
would they talk about you as as a
partner in general do you know i mean we
don't get to hear that narrative so it's
like okay cool one of the reasons is
probably why kevin samuel said you don't
get any hard on your baby daddy because
like you know what you picked him like
it's what you've done and so can i just
say sierra yeah
i was about to say hello
i have a question do you look like
sierra do you look like sierra do i look
like sierra i don't look like like
no i'm saying i'm saying like this is
this is this is a girl that's a nine
and then i was right about to say before
everybody said this i was about to say
people lot people love because it's
relatable to go to the famous examples
yeah but i just want to say even though
you've just said it my point was going
to be people go to the high-end
relatable examples of this but what do
they well i mean they're there really
they're not average jane though but we
can see them though so yeah
but average james come average james
feel like it's a relatable example why
is it relatable you know what going back
to what the lady was saying before in
the green dress i feel what she's saying
because you know really even just never
yes i'm sure sometimes
to a degree i feel what she's saying
because even though she has got two
children etc etc the way she carries
herself a man could fall in love with
her really yes
but that's like women are emotional so
you're looking at this from a girl's
point of view because you're thinking
like oh if i met a guy and he just
charmed me the right way like i could
fall in love and like a lot of girls do
like they'll say oh i'll never date that
that and that and then their next
boyfriend is that like men are more
logical it's like a costs and a minuses
[ __ ] okay like so she looks she can look
great and they keep like all right fall
in love with her but he knows at the end
of the day he's going to be taken on her
two boys
so
now he's got a way up okay cool i might
love her but
i'm gonna be one taking over our
household two going into a household
with two boys who know i'm not their
father yeah like you know i mean like
all of these stuff has got a way up so
it's like
yeah
you know you can have two children and
look good but like i said on the
quote-unquote dating market
are guys looking for you and she would
rather by the way
she clearly what i took from earlier
honestly that was somebody who would
rather be with nobody yeah then be with
anybody who it was felt like wasn't on
her plateau yeah so that's fine
but then
the conundrum again is the man name who
you view on your plateau one what
exactly from you and then the men and
then the men who
and then the men who made because you
see one thing people don't necessarily
talk about is the fact that well you
know what
when men say that the sort of men who
would step into a pre-made family and
yeah
some men say that you know that's a
that's a little weaker
than than the man who
who is not doing that i would say any
man that does that to be a step dad
actually i think this is a strong god
and i think i would i would admire him
because he's taken on a lot of deaths um
yeah the worst
baby mom you'd admire him come on bro to
some degree i wouldn't i wouldn't
seriously if a guy if i gotta tell you i
don't because
if a guy if a guy tells me that he's
would date a single mother i'm like
like i feel like your your vetting
skills are off like because to me it's
just not wise
it's not smart like to me there's
something and it's one thing like i
think if you both have kids that's a
different situation
um i mean i think like men i think
people can
date each other
wait hold on do you want to finish your
point yeah about um why you would do it
i wouldn't do it i don't think i have to
strength but absolutely any man who does
it yes i think i do admire him if he did
can you explain why
i think it's sacrificial the fact that
you're willing to um take all the
deficit
to make a um extended family with
someone that has it's not your kid it's
not something i would do
[Music]
it was a lesson that
i had to learn do you get what i'm
saying like it was a lesson that i had
to learn so i wouldn't advise it yeah
however like i said and i've said this
before
men over over a certain age
if they're looking for a woman of a
certain aca around 30 yeah chances are
yeah they're going to have a child
maybe a child or two you know i mean so
that's something you got away up but i'm
saying men who are like under 30 yeah
who are like in the prime of their life
if they're looking to get with a woman
who's got a child you're an idiot yeah
it's not the wise i won't say it's not
the wisest
to say to say it's weak i think the
biological father not looking after
these kids that's weak but then why is
that your immediate assumption because
no i'm just i'm saying i'm saying it's
like this is showing a gynocentric
social order and especially like i know
you're involved in the church especially
in the church it's like this coddling of
women nah she broke the home more than
likely she probably left no no no i
would agree in general but i'm just
saying if any man
wants to step in i think there is
something admirable when i'm doing that
i'm not advocating that like sarah said
he's had experience of it and i don't
think i'll have the strength to do that
but i'm just saying i won't necessarily
call that man weak
i would and i'll tell you why because
the laws are just stacked against men
so you could be on the hook for child
support of a kid that's not yours like
to me that's just stupid like i said
it's not the wisest decision as someone
who's done it you what you were and the
thing is yeah i speak to me he's a donor
he's not offended no no no no no i i
speak to men who have done it
as well and like i said we've said it so
many times
you get 100 percent of the
responsibility as a father and you do
not get the authoritarian role 100
percent either so
legal rights you have no legal rights of
all the responsibility so it is not a
good thing to do in the long run it's
really not the smartest thing to do
a lesson that i had to learn for myself
but is it not down to the man to then
represent as represent himself as a
father to that child so that the father
but it will be hard for him it will be
hard if you if you unders if you
understand
um mothers of children right mothers of
children have a they have a biological
connection to their child
and
they know that you don't have that
biological connection to that child
right and so whether consciously or
subconsciously they will let you know
that that's not your biological child
and it's not and it's not in it's not in
the most um
you know uh
forward
way possible and like i said a lot of it
is subconscious a lot of it is little
things that are down here at all if i
was a dad i would have been able to do
that but you know so i'm saying it's not
it's not a very good um
uh setup yeah i take your point sorry in
terms of if you're older in your 50s and
you're ready
when you look at it from a cost benefit
analysis is how men think if you're in
your 20s just about to your career's
about to take off yeah and you meet a
single mom with two sons run you're
thinking why would i do that no
seriously yeah yeah i've just seen it
from a
superficial this is this run
there's no need for a man of that age to
be getting with a single one yeah
because what she's looking for at that
age is a stepfather for her children
yeah oh i have a question do you feel
like single mother mothers can ask for
monogamy
yes
yeah i do
yeah
because you're kind of cheating them out
of the things that men value right
you're there there's clearly no purity
there
so so and you're asking a guy to
compromise his mating strategy right
which is screw as many people as
possible
and your mating strategy is to get all
the resources and it's like you're
asking for a full compromise when like
it's like one-sided go ahead i don't
understand this why is this one of men's
um what did you say is there a mating
strategy no like the things that they
hold whatever
why
okay but are you
a second why are you holding purity at
high regard when you're out here beating
every chick so the re the reason is
because somebody understand that men and
women are different and that's the thing
like if a girl has had sex with one
person they're a virgin she has an 80
chance of a happy marriage if she slept
with more than five it goes down to 25
chance of 10 years having a happy
marriage so it's less valuable to a man
where like a dude the number one best is
if they're both virgins but if you take
that off the table like men's marital
happiness increases like from five to
eight partners where they're more happy
with the girl because we we bond more
during sex i mean that's why we have
terms like dickmatized
and can we be honest women do want a man
with sexual experience let's just be
honest that's why it's different women
do not want a man especially when it's
time to get to that sexual place they
don't want a man that they've got to
teach
they want they would prefer to be taught
by a man but a woman doesn't want a man
with no sex experience he wants to have
a man that doesn't know he's in his
bedroom
you're going to need a man who's got
sexual experience hence the reason why
he's that he cannot be out here banging
all the chicks because he's trying to
get some experience for you maybe i
don't know i think it just depends on
the on the person yeah i'd agree i don't
personally i wouldn't want to date
someone with no sexual experience but
then
that's just me but yeah but that means
he's got a
experience
i think right now like right now so you
want a guy with experience you want a
guy with sex like that's what i'm trying
to say
experience like why would you disagree
with say the same thing
he doesn't know he doesn't know how to
talk to women doesn't know how to
approach women guys that do that that
doesn't have had experience yeah but he
can have experience but it doesn't mean
he has to have sexual experience she
couldn't have to approach a lady he may
have he may have her experience with
leah and rachel
it's the same me
what i value is a man who's got
discipline so a man who hasn't been out
in the streets like being
every chick but
doesn't he doesn't he have to know how
to speak to you as a woman and get you
to the point where you're thinking
but this is another reason why i value
family because if he comes from a family
where you know he has male figures
around him then
nine times out of ten they probably know
how to speak to the women within their
family why they've got a good unit and
that's been passed down to him so he
hasn't learned how to do these things on
the streets and i think that's a very
big issue in our society we shouldn't be
learning a lot of stuff from society we
should be learning it from the primary
point of education which is the home the
family it's like we say it takes a
village right so i feel like there's a
problem which
you know we need to get to the root of
and it's like the family unit no i i
agree with you i do think it's the
family unit but but a lot of times like
you're you're putting an old set of
values in 2022.
we can't undo birth control and although
a lot of the reason for a lack of family
is the women
it's it's us we don't want to get
married the average age of first
marriage is 31. listen i'm just gonna
put it out there i'm trying to get
married
i'm trying to get married like i'm a
career-driven woman however my biggest
aspiration in life is to get married and
have a family that that's paramount to
everything because the family structure
is important for society it's not just
important for just the family like it's
a trickle effect it helps the economy
yeah so i think that's what a lot of
people need to realize but um yeah i
think people need to stop being so
selfish and successful
so you see how most um
correct me if i'm wrong fellow panelists
yeah but most of us when we entered the
dating game in teenage years pb whatever
the men amongst us we stepped in the
game understanding that we're the
hunters
and that depending on how we're able to
hunt
that is going to directly correlate with
our success in the dating game and most
women have walked into the dating game
ready made
iqr like yeah ready-made ikr i'm aware
that it is now the onus is on men to
impress me and to coerce me and to
and so and so wim so men
depending on where they've come from in
their home life
may struggle with that than others
the men who struggle with that most
likely are given no allowance from the
women of their generation like they
don't give allowances for the men that
might have a social deficit because they
grew up with no dad there's no allowance
for that they're just looked over
instead of the men who did have a dad
and grew up with a certain masculinity
um ingrained
yeah this is where communication is
clear
well my thing well my thing is basically
what i'm trying to say is that you know
you have someone like alizo yeah
lizzo doesn't find men who look like
lizzo attractive you know what i'm
saying lizzo's a hero but dj khaled's a
joke
she's what i'm trying to say that you go
on the internet you see that he's a joke
she's a hero do you know what i mean
they're both they're both generally like
in general society i think personally i
don't
sorry but most my my point being
basically what i'm trying to say
basically is right yeah
is that
there's a certain thing that in
i've noticed it i'm a man i'm not gay i
date women of all different levels i
understand it does work in levels right
and
you know
not a lot of not all women from my own
experiences really have any concept of
the idea that they would ever be in a
position where they'd meet a man that
they would have to graft for and that
they would have to earn do you know what
i mean yeah yeah and be competitive well
it's always it's always you're the prize
as well yeah
when so so then it's kind of like
whereas men obviously trial and error
meet different women and understand what
it is about them that maybe leads them
to success with some women and not
others basically what i'm trying to say
is that all men ask anyone in here they
know where they rank is what i'm trying
to say yeah yeah they know where they
rank they've because they've had to go
through it they've had ds's and the nose
yeah whereas whereas women more so when
we talk about dating
they rank wherever they choose to rank i
i fancy who i choose to fancy right
whereas men are more realistic in the
sense that well i can fancy beyonce all
i want but i know i can't get it do you
know what i mean right and it's not
because i'm a pessimist it's because
it's because reality hits men hard yeah
like we go on a dating app like you can
get you can get attention from a dude
that's way out of your league that would
never be seen in public with you
thank you yeah but that's the problem
because women are getting
women are getting [ __ ] down by men
right they're out of their league right
it doesn't mean they want to stay with
them no but that's what i'm trying to
say so a lot of women because they're
getting [ __ ] down by men that are out
of their league they think oh i can
attract it it's quite yeah
it's like no you can have a footballer
to have sex with you that doesn't mean
he's going to put a ring on your feet
100 there's a difference i'm gonna read
the super chats real quick okay guys if
you want to be a member okay if you want
to be involved in the chat sign up for
our memberships five dollar tier you're
involved in the chat ten dollar cheer we
have discord and we also have two bonus
vlogs that are really cool so
yeah you guys should sign up for the ten
dollar tier two so i'm going to read the
super chats real quick
jack i wish i could slap angel and his
mouth um das token you can't save for
retirement if you're wasting your time
energy and money dealing with another
man's seed they can't request
monogamy she's a wench
jonathan adams have to live in two
spectrums biblical in the world jonathan
adams joy only comes from happiness when
thin
happiness is expressed death's token i
miss when women loved babies not hated
them
death token e30
men do a lot better of a job raising
kids kids needs discipline men provide
discipline a moms a lot of the time are
pushovers everyone knows that
b mackel's
lady in the green is not submissive zip
your mouth dash token e30 there's no
split ac units in the uk
red savage pearl don't let the modern
women steal your energy keep the
optimistic energy you always have
respect
dc081
holy hell pearl the couch is a headache
and then we have let me refresh it real
quick so
yeah guys if you want to be involved in
the chat sign up for our memberships the
other thing that's great about
memberships is it gives us a reliable
source of income every month like views
they'll come and they'll go they'll come
and they'll go but when you guys are a
part of our memberships it keeps the
lights on it keeps the rent paid it
keeps ish here
um
and on top of that all super chats will
be read we are saving to get ish a
camera
oh you're next time okay oh yeah of
course yeah i'm a little busy right now
yeah okay okay okay so um yeah send
super chat sign up for our memberships
and you go ahead oh okay yeah okay no
problem it just confused me yeah so
ladies i don't know if you um heard when
we were gone right um thank you for
coming back by the way um
i was i had a question like
would your
um
baby fathers
would your baby fathers at the fathers
of your children
say that you are good
co-parents
just a simple yes
yeah
what what makes a good co-parenting
situation do you think
i think their mics are muted
oh sorry
i think i'm very understanding of his
situation um i understand that life
happens life can literally be life and
so if there's certain things he can't do
i'm quite understanding of it and i will
never ever keep his child from him
okay
do you think your partner would say that
you're a good co-parent yeah
um what makes a good core parent
situation um the kids come first our
personal beliefs or feelings is not what
is important
um their safety their security
their health is what i deem first
um i've kind of detached from my own
personal feelings towards him it's just
about the kids now so
if i thought for some reason he's not
been as community of communitive with
the kids
i'm more than happy to take the
initiative to reach out to him to speak
to them mm-hmm so as the mother they are
they in your care majorities
so
do you see
when a lot of i've spoken to a lot of
fathers i'm part of like a
father's group and stuff like that right
and a lot of the stuff that fathers say
is that um
a lot of people don't understand when
men
leave their children
right they can't understand it and a lot
of the times i've spoken to fathers for
years now that have left their children
and one of the main reasons why they've
left is because they've realized
that they're not going to become someone
else's pawn in the game
so a lot of the time like
mothers make fathers jump through hoops
do you know what i mean take the child
from like just basically do what they
want and a lot of the reason why men say
you know what i can't deal with this and
walk away is because it's just not
willing to and do you think that's right
i don't condone any man um
walking away from his child but i will
say that every person has a breaking
point and i will say that every person
um
uh is that yeah every person has a
breakup there's there's cases where guys
have spent like fifty thousand dollars
and they still can't see their kids
that's fair but there's no breaking
point they'll be given to me that would
stop me from being a parent yeah
i would put my pride my ego everything
aside i will even act like i love you if
i have to for my kids but the the the
issue is that the justice system is in
our favor so a lot of times there's like
nothing that the guy can do
and so we we reviewed a video the other
day right yeah oh my god that was such a
sad story literally in this video though
the mother took the kid to japan
like what is he
and he hasn't yeah he just hasn't seen
it and i'm just like seeing the child
sorry it's that hasn't seen a child
since and you know i've spoken to a few
fathers you know
i think do you think that mothers have
too much power when it comes to truth i
think men are quite
ignorant and naive they don't actually
know the system because i know a lot of
men that have fought for their kids and
they actually have custody of their
children i think they do what they know
and i think society has made it that
women are like primary carers they favor
women blah blah blah but if you
genuinely know and you study the system
there are ways that you can
have rights to your children do you
think that mother should have more
rights than fathers
when it comes to children if a woman
turned around and said to you that oh
she wants to give full custody to the
father and she wants to be
free you would look at her in a certain
way like what kind of mother are you
so you can't pick and choose when you
want to give the power to the woman
no i'm saying we're saying like i would
say it should immediately be 50 50.
unless there's abuse that's the only
situation it should be 50 50. do you
guys believe in child support like
well i don't i don't ask for child
support oh okay cool
i feel um i feel like it should happen
but like i said i'm realistic if
my child is not
an item that needs to be managed my
child so i'll look after you i'll do
what i need to if you can't think of
doing the same as a father then that's
on you
if that if the father pays like child
support do you think he should get 50 50
custody with the chart with the child if
you want to yeah no
oh no
why not because some fathers choose to
pay child support because they don't
want to be in the child's life
so if we're talking about the things
that do the ones that do yeah we were
talking about the fathers that do want
to be in their child's life um do i
believe in child support in that
instance
um depending on how the situation played
out i think that one is circumstantial
you see when it comes to 50 50 i think
no offense it's all about your parenting
skills for me if your parenting skills
don't align
then or your parenting skills are not a
positive impact on the child then i
don't think you should have 50 50
because it confuses the child if we
can't sit make that decision we can sit
down together
and say okay this is what i think like
for instance don't let the kids watch
certain things don't let kids eat drink
certain things so you know they must
read they must do that and if i see that
we've we've established that that's what
should happen and that's not being done
then you can't have 50 because the
things that we're asking for that i'm
asking for is something to benefit the
child it's not got anything personal to
do with me or to do with anything that i
think i think definitely
like i come from a family of ten and
they were very loose like we could
pretty much do whatever we wanted and
that young from from like yeah no like
really a lot of freedom and everyone
turned out good they're functioning
membership uh sorry two parent homes yes
yeah but that's right and so i both
agree right but what i'm saying is that
you how do you know you're correct like
maybe that's his parenting style would
have been better
i think it yeah on actually having a
conversation
like she said because i feel like me
personally if for example you don't want
your kids to watch tv at three doesn't
necessarily mean i'm a bad parent but
yeah i do 100 because i my my child
watches tv whatever she wants yeah but
that doesn't necessarily mean i'm
raising her the wrong way
if i'm seeing impacts of their behavior
changing at school and it's being raised
to my it's been brought to my attention
and stuff like that then we need to
discuss like
whether we're not together that's so
different from these kids we need i
believe when you choose to be a single
parent you have to realize that it's
probably harder than being in together
being together is a lot easier than
being a single parent
so you now have to learn how to have
people skills management skills all of
that because
there's going to be some sort of
resentment
until you've healed right so i feel like
you have to be able to sit down and talk
together and say okay this is what i
want what do you want or this is what i
want okay let's meet halfway and if you
can't have those kind of conversations
together then it's just gonna be
difficult well no i agree it'll be
difficult i just don't like like to me
that's not enough to ask for not
splitting custody my children for me my
children's upbringing is enough for me
to well i'm saying like i don't think
legally that's fair it may not be fair
legally but so many things are not fair
legally so well i know they benefit the
women typically but i've said that yeah
yeah i've said that but um there's some
men as well they're not happy with the
way women bring
women as well not all women raise
children well mm-hmm so it's not i don't
even think it should be a based on
the male sex yeah i think i think it's
just a bit who's a better parent and
it's hard you know what some people
won't accept him but some men are better
parents than women as well but no i i
agree but i'm saying i'm saying like off
the bat i think it should be 50 50.
and if there's no abuse it should stay
50 55. i agree and i don't think
anyone's entitled to child support i
don't understand like why
you get a reward i think a child's
putting up a home child support should
be offered to you if you are financially
not capable of looking to the child then
i think there's nothing wrong with that
but then shouldn't they just give the
child to the more financially stable
parent but financially being financially
stable doesn't make you a good parent
either it makes it much better for the
child i can give you money to like i can
give you so okay wouldn't you agree that
typically people that are financially
responsible typically are responsible in
other areas of their life
in general like i know there's
exceptions but we're talking about the
rule when i look at parents with
rich parents and their kids have gone to
private school those are the most
problematic kids well we're not talking
about wealth no i'm just looking for
reflecting back to wealth so for me for
some reason money doesn't necessarily
make me feel like you're a good parent
you may be controlling your life like
you may save well
what would you say indicates in a legal
perspective who's a good parent
you know what i think feelings is so
hard
things that you can't measure there's no
metrics
it's finances
yeah if you can make sure
because i just don't know what else
because if you're
if you can't support yourself and a kid
on some on some level that says you were
irresponsible and typically you are
irresponsible in not just one area of
your life but in multiple i think
legally i think they look at a child's
stability
finances are like definitely a big part
of it and obviously the support the
families the support system the unit and
i feel like that's very important so if
for example i'm like [ __ ] with finances
and i don't have families just me and my
child they could probably give the child
to the dad who has his brothers sisters
aunties uncles cousins and he's making
more a bit more money but in terms of
finances just because i'm struggling
with my child doesn't mean
a two like two income is always going to
be better than one so if he's given 200
pounds a month let's say
that doesn't affect him
in that way to make it seem like he's
more financially stable he could still
be given 200 pounds and earning less
than me to to look after a child takes
however much i think if he was living
under the same roof
the
the financial aspect will still be the
same exactly they would still be
spending money on their like child
whether they're living with their child
or whether they don't live with you
exactly
um well yeah i mean i just think that i
don't like the idea of the government
like
forcing them to spend money
if it's not 50 50 though
even so i just don't think you're
entitled to a man's money so what do you
think
men put women on child support as well i
that's the exception it's not the rule
typically it's the other way around and
i'm not i'm not for that either i'm not
for child support at all so what do you
tell you what was it
what do you think what do you think
should happen i think like honestly you
should make better decisions of who you
make a kid with because like to me like
there's always a bailout for women if we
make a bad decision like someone always
bails us out like any do you mean
government government
everything so like for example if
someone gets fat there's fat phobic
right if someone if someone if someone
has a high body count sleeps around
they're slut-shaming like they don't
have the equivalent of that for men um
in this instance i'm saying like you get
money from the government
i just really or or from or from the guy
so i wouldn't be able to comment on this
because i don't personally take child
support right right i'm decision with my
baby father but that's the choice i made
and i'm dealing with it no and that's
that's the thing i respect people that
take accountability but it's like it's
like
to me i don't think anyone should bail
anyone out for their bad decisions so if
you choose to make a child with a less a
subpar guy i don't think you're entitled
to his money you should have picked
better but then the man had played just
as much of a part to create that child
as a woman no no because women are in
charge of birth it's your own fault if
you get pregnant
because because we have we have 10 to 15
forms of birth control even if we get
pregnant you can get an abortion yeah
but a man still has to it's hot in here
um
yeah but yeah but the thing is a man
having access to a woman's body
is the woman he gets
he gets permission from the woman
but he doesn't get permission to like
ejaculate yeah but you know as a woman
that if you give a man access to
um if you give a man access to your body
you know what the consequence so what
happens when grape is involved so that's
it like america right now you can't have
abortions
oh sorry
no no it's just sorry we talk a lot
we're just saying that's the exception
that's less than one percent of them
that's like a half a percent of
abortions yeah when actually 40 of women
that have had abortions have had two or
more already so the majority of
abortions really is just a form of birth
control because i can't imagine like how
you get pregnant i honestly think that i
i definitely believe men and women are
not equal right i've always believed
that there's certain things that women
can't get away with in certain things
that men can't get away with it but why
do we always antagonize the things that
women can get away with and not the
things that men can example being
a man can sleep around
he's because we said this before
women want a man with sexual experience
and you don't want a woman with sexual
if you're if you're having a fellatio
i'll explain sorry hold on hold on
because you asked so i said
women want men with sexual experience
so if you got if you got with a guy yeah
yeah and he had no sexual experience you
wouldn't be attracted to him why
because he doesn't because he doesn't
know what he's doing in the bedroom
because because there's dialogue there's
there's a statistical there's there's no
way i'm saying but but okay so you've
got attraction before then it's time to
have sex okay and he doesn't know what
the hell he's doing okay right
it's are you going to continue that
relationship if he's teachable yes so
like hang on majority of women don't
want to teach men how to lie
where's the statistics
okay so once so on there's biological
reasons for the reasons we feel the way
we feel if a guy can get other girls
it's a form of pre-selection
so so that signals to us he could take
care of those women therefore he can
take care of me too so that's why it's
attractive to us a man that's been with
more women on the other hand men value
purity because their biological
imperative was they don't want to put
resources into a kid that's not theirs
and so that's why they value a lower
body count because if they don't want to
they don't they want to make sure that
kid is theirs and then if you want to
talk about body count so a woman that's
only had that's a virgin when she gets
married she has an eighty percent chance
of a happy marriage within 10 years
she's not going to if she's if she's if
she's okay again we're talking about
the stats so this 80 chance of a of a
happy marriage in 10 years if you slept
with more than five people which i think
most men pray for nowadays
their chance of a happy marriage is 25
so it goes from 80 to 25
so and and it keeps dropping lower and
lower go ahead can i ask you a question
so if you got with a woman who didn't
have any sexual experience
would you
um
you teach her
okay and if she wasn't really getting
the hang of it uh a man
is um
more willing to be a teacher of a woman
sexually mm-hmm than a woman is to be
i'm not saying that you're not i'm just
saying but if she wasn't getting the
hang of it what would you do well she'd
get it
no you can't say she'd get it
no you can't you can't say no because i
know what kind of time in this scenario
in this scenario i'm giving you
she's not getting it so what would you
do well then i'd leave
after you got married so oh after
marriage yeah i'm not having i'm not
having i haven't married you and not had
sex with you oh okay also you would have
sex with my age oh 100 so if she wasn't
good in bed you wouldn't marry her
no like like you were saying if she was
confident
if she was constantly being taught and
she didn't know what she was doing then
the relationship so she so ultimately
she wasn't good in bed yeah you wouldn't
marry her
uh i'd probably speak elsewhere yeah so
you wouldn't marry her
why is it such a while there's a lower
bar for a girl to be good in bed than
there is
a man can have a wife
a man can have sex with a hole in the
wall not know who's on the other side
okay and be absolutely satisfied with
what you just got okay then why wouldn't
you women why wouldn't you marry her
then
because you can have sex with a hole in
the wall all you need is a hole right
if i can finish women want to feel a lot
of time when i have sex
emotionally connected to the person that
they're having sex with and man doesn't
necessarily have to be emotionally
connected so why would you leave because
because of marriage
i need more than i need more from her in
a marriage than just sex so why would
you leave if it's not just about sex
about what they're doing why would you
leave because because sex is such is a
very big thing for a man but there's
more but there's more to it in a
marriage and you can [ __ ] think
that's got a whole thank you that's one
contradictory hang on
if i choose a woman if i choose her and
i like her qualities
and she can't have sex right then if if
i would weigh up
hmm she's got good qualities
my marriage
might cheat on her
so okay i'm just gonna actually be real
with you but if she's got the qualities
that she that is more than just sex i
will choose her okay but if she can't if
if if she's if she can give good sex and
she's got no wife qualities she's not
getting wife so you'd marry you might
marry her but you'd cheat on her yeah
probably if she doesn't know what is
that wouldn't you say it's kind of a
reflection of the girl if you're bad at
sex because it's like yeah but you want
your teeth
or a bad protection no no i'm saying
like it's it's a like she's not trying
if you like if he knows if he knows it
no if he knows exactly what he wants and
he says this is what you have to do
like i don't know yeah it's like well
same way women know what women can say
to a man this is what i want in a in a
relationship and you don't get it well
the problem is women don't know what
they want absolutely you're making a
very very broad statement because women
change their minds all the time
women are known for changing their minds
can i can i just go back the sex thing
so
you
believe that women want men with
experience yeah women want men with
sexual experience yeah we want men with
experience right
your experience doesn't mean you know
how to please me
just because you've pleased every woman
in this room doesn't mean you know how
to please my body yeah but he's shown
you what you know how to do is have sex
yes but he but he he's shown you that he
he can have sex how are you showing me
because you told me what your butt
account is yeah he's showing you that i
like you you can't you
that can get girls that's why he got you
what i'm talking about sex right now i'm
not talking about getting you know
having sex are two different things if
it's where you have money then you can
say that but if it's about sex there is
definitely nothing talking about the
sexual markets yeah even if it's not the
monetary
i think i'm delusional because i i think
you guys need to maybe educate me right
because from my delusional brain what i
believe is just because you've had sex
with 50 girls doesn't mean you know how
to please me you learn how to please me
from the frequency of how much we have
sex because i always believe the first
time you have sex with someone
maybe if you're in lust with each other
you feel like it's heightened you enjoy
it but as the sex goes on i feel like it
improves because you get to understand
each other and you know each other's
body right so just because you've slept
with 10 girls or 50 girls or whatever i
don't think you know how to please me
you have to understand why didn't you
taylor make your sexual relationship
with him then
but no i'm just basing it on what you
just said so i'm saying you can't say
your experience with sex you're good at
sex just because you had six okay girls
okay baby
we're saying we're saying that by and
large men that have sex more tend to be
better at sex okay so i'm not i'm not
saying
i'm not i'm not saying that every single
guy that slept with 100 girls knows how
to screw them right some guys don't care
they don't want to do that but by and
large like if you do something more you
get better at it if i play football
every sunday am i more likely to be a
better goal scorer than someone who
doesn't play
if you have experience doing something
that's what attracts you to the person
you know that person has had sexual
experience would you want a virgin man
so can i would you want a virgin you
would want
can i just say there are a lot of people
would you want a virgin man i do you
know what if he's
there
he puts the most high first and i'm
asking you like seriously would you want
a virgin man if he's god yeah would you
hang on not you do you want a virgin man
no right so you want a mammy's sexual
experience yeah but not that much sexual
experience can i just say what do you
mean that much
i've never specified how much that's
what i'm trying to say you're actually
arguing a point that you actually agree
with i don't get it i'm not arguing a
point that i agree with you agree with
the point what i'm saying is
in terms of just because you've had a
lot of sex does not make you good at sex
a lot of people that have had a lot of
sex that think they are good at sex but
if you ask a person they last had sex
with they'll be like nah i didn't enjoy
the sex that is not your argument the
argument is that women want a man with
sexual experience no one has no one has
disagreed with that though who agree who
did it
but
sorry darling my statement was why do
you think because you've had sex with
more people you can please me that's
what my statement was it wasn't about
women
but the point i was making is women as
women as you you've said today women
want a man with sex rich you don't want
a virgin man right you don't want a
virgin but you want to know a man
can at least know
something in the bedroom you don't want
a virgin man so my point is the reason
why it's different for men and women
sleeping around is because men want a
woman who is who has less sexual
experience
women want a man with sexual experience
does that make sense but they both have
sexual experience
what do you mean you said that the woman
has less but the more less but they both
have sexual experiences yeah less or
zero less also
can i just ask a question so who are the
men sleeping with
what you mean uh women with more i'm
just trying to i'm just trying to
understand they're not women that they
sleep with so they're sleeping with
women with more sexual experience but
you've got to understand they're
sleeping with women with more sexual
experience on the basis that they have
no intention to wife them
okay so and we'll say earlier on a lot
of a lot of women can have sex with men
yeah
and think that because they're having
sex with men that they're of that
caliber i agree
yeah yeah so men don't just because you
can have sex with a footballer
100 well 100 of women want 20 of men and
some some some surveys say 5 10 15 so
you have 100 of the women sleeping with
a smaller percentage
and yeah so if you all want so like i
said that goes back to you want a
mammoth sexual experience because if
women are looking for that 20 of men
we already know that 20 of men have got
sexual experience because they've got
women throwing themselves at them on a
constant basis so have you agreed that
just because you had sex with 50 people
doesn't mean you can please me yeah you
agree with that right yes
do you have a need to be right right now
is that what it is
right wrong you made a statement about
having a look that's what i was bringing
up yeah no no we said by and large guys
guys that have sex more tend to be
better at sex i said it does not mean
that every single guy that's had sex
with a lot of girls is gonna be some
kind some some some guys are just trying
to get in and get out but you what but
you want that man you want the man that
you know has had sex experience that's
my point he might not be able to please
you but you want him because you know
he's had sex experience you don't want
the virgin man you want the one that's
got sex
right so like i said i don't know what
he can do in the bedroom he could be
he could be great it could be [ __ ] but
the point is you want that man with
sexual experience okay
i don't ask about body count yeah i
don't ask about body count i just think
it's so unnecessary
well yeah that's it that's a female
point of view though
like we've had people on our portal
we've had debates in general and
majority of the guys that are a certain
maturity don't care about body counts i
feel like because they don't they don't
want to know
they don't want it
they just rather not know if a guy knew
you slept with like 500 guys trust me
you'd want to know i feel like he
i think as females as well you don't
want to be with someone who's easily
accessible that is a turn off so i can
understand a man that doesn't want to be
with a girl that has left with tom dick
and harry
but i don't want to be with someone
who's easily accessible yeah women don't
want that it's distasteful to you know
imagine walking with your guy or even
your girl yeah and someone's like oh
so if drake wanted to make you his wife
would that be a problem i don't think
drake will want to make me i know no i'm
just saying i'm not delusional i'm not
drinking no but no but what i'm trying
to say if you enjoy someone that popular
yeah it's someone popular because you're
saying
you'd only be walking with someone who's
been accessible drake has probably had i
don't know i'm not putting this stuff
out there you probably have sex with a
lot of women right he wanted my wife me
i'd be in
i wouldn't believe it but like i
wouldn't would you would you actually be
with a drake with everything you
believing and how you are and everything
would you be with drake would i would i
be with drake probably i mean i would
have a man i'd say would that not be oh
wait no he has a kid right i really
don't oh yeah
but the thing is but you or you know
women break their rules for the right
man i agree but they accept agreements
they break their rules for the right man
do you think men do that what do you
mean break their rules for the right
everyone breaks their rules for the
right person
everyone does i i i know it sounds like
i'm capping but i i don't like attention
too much i don't like stress i know i
can handle and there's girls that are
far prettier than me so i wouldn't go
with a drake i don't think i'm drinks
i'm not his market i'm always talking
targeted audience
do you know what i mean i feel so you're
saying you know your level yeah yeah i
know my boundaries 100
that's fair yeah that's fair
if a guy of a certain caliber comes to
me the first thing i'm thinking is you
want to have sex with me oh yeah no
that's why i said i wouldn't take it
like yeah yes
if i had a guarantee i'd be wife like
what the i would do it yeah i think i'm
even it sounds mad right but i feel like
i'll even be more careful how soon i let
him sleep with me because i feel like
he's already here for the sex anyway no
that's that's um that's called alpha
widow like like have you heard the term
alpha widow an alpha widow basically
like
have you ever had a friend where there's
that one x that she cannot get over
so it doesn't matter who the next guy is
she's still thinking of that last guy
that's because that was the guy that she
felt like was the best that she could do
so as women i think we have an internal
like guard up against sleeping with
someone that's too high of a status
because we know if we sleep with them we
can't get over it
yeah i wouldn't sleep with you because i
just don't want to be one of many and i
don't think you're taking me seriously
and my mind frame right now is to be
serious but if i was on like city girl
behavior oh come here 100 oh so i have a
question do you guys think you can wait
till you're married after you've had a
kid
like do you think that's a if you're
waiting for six yeah for sex till you're
married after you've had a kid yeah
i can do
you can you yeah
so do you think actually because i have
a kid
so you think you can have a child
become single meet a new man
and that new man now has to wait until
mary's have sex with you if i'm
intentional with what i want to with
what i want to do if i if for example if
my if i've decided my next relationship
is i'm going to get married right
they're 100
and and it's how realistic you think it
is
you've already shown that you would give
it's not about showing it's what i was
sure about she's married so why would it
not i'm talking it's a hypothetical yeah
okay okay cool like you can say i have
cool i have a child what's that got to
do with you
if i don't want to have sex with you i
don't want to have sex with you if i
want to wait until i'm married again
then i don't then i'll just do that and
and and for me
for example god forbid if i get divorced
i'm taking my christianity life a lot
more seriously like because whatever a
lot more seriously because
because the next man whatever the next
decision decision i make is going to
affect my children directly and i don't
and as you guys said picking men you
have to make good decisions so i'd 100
percent i'd i guess one question i have
one question um
did you
wait
before
did you have sex before marriage before
so you had sex before marriage yeah
what you didn't wait with the first
person no well that doesn't determine
what i'm going to do
no but it's just it's just it's just
it's just it's from it's from a man's
point of view it's like from operating
it's there you're putting a higher price
for a used product yeah that's fine if
you want which is which is that no
you're
you can do whatever you want but like
this is why i personally see a lot of
single childless women in the church or
single or single mothers because it's
they're asking too high of a price for
what their best buyer is willing to pay
when they could when they could get a
better buyer is this statistic
let me just put this out let me just put
this out here
i'm not going to let you
determine what my value is
i don't care what anybody says if if i
don't want to have sex with you and you
feel just because i have a child you
should be able to receive sex from me
then
rather keep it can i just say yeah
that's like me getting a car a used car
saying pay a hundred thousand dollars
for it and say oh you're the problem if
nobody buys no i didn't say that when
did i say that
i just
understand the analogy no i understand
the analogy but you always have you said
that's always true
you have a choice to walk away i if if i
do not want to have sex with you and you
feel that because i've had a child you
have access to me like that you ha and i
said no you have the choice
as a man coming to a woman who has
probably already had a child probably
had a marriage i'm just using your
example say you were divorced and you've
got a child you had a husband
what i can see is a woman who's been
through life okay right she's been
through life okay but what you're asking
me
hypothetically what you're asking me to
do is to act as if you ain't seen no
life like you don't you're asking me to
act like you ain't got kids no you ain't
had a husband like no one's already
yes because
i disagree sorry sorry can i just say we
would have had conversations as well i
would have i would have asked you what
your values are i would have seen if
they're in alignment alignment with mine
if they're not i wouldn't be on it
anyway so
that's just it like it doesn't have
everything isn't basically i don't think
there's a value don't you think there's
actually a value in the sexual
marketplace or in the relationship
marketplace just like regardless of
i might have a vintage car right and it
could be i could have such sentimental
like you know attachment to that car but
on the actual car market it's worth a
certain thing now i can think it's worth
more than that right
but it's not on the car market so on the
market that you're looking at do you
think that you asking for that price is
realistic okay
does that make sense yeah 100 putting it
in relationship experience or situation
i'm not delusional like if for example
if i was divorced two kids i'm not
delusional to what i can get i'm not
going to ask a single man that doesn't
have children that's 25 that can have
whatever he wants to wait for me
like you have to be realistic if you are
for example if i got divorced now i'm
not going with anybody that doesn't have
children
i'm not
because there's one it's just easier
it's just like getting with another
black person it's just there's certain
things we just don't need to talk about
it's just easier so maybe our values
will our market value might be the same
or similar
so and and as i said there will be i
don't think you understand the mind of
men okay
so can i just ask is a man that has
children divorced whatever is he still
of the same value as a man that's single
um no of course okay then that's it then
of course he isn't but the thing is men
know this sounds like that's the thing
like a lot of women try to convince
themselves that they're over a higher
value
um and they're not like men as i'm a man
with i've got a child i know that me
having a child
is going to put me out of certain
certain
certain rooms with when it comes to
women and i'm actually fine with that
but a lot of the time women think oh
well i've got a child i can get this
like love calm like you have you
but the thing is a lot of childless
women don't mind dating guys with kids
like i would say i'm more the exception
rather than the rule of like people my
age
i don't think so i think a lot i think a
lot of women
because you know there's not that many
good women and good men anymore i think
women are you know bending there that's
what she's saying and she's saying
that's what she said
i'm agreeing with you
but no i'm saying that they're willing
to check other places that they won't
normally go with okay but i wanted to
ask you a question
so based on you know your stats and your
experience and your knowledge what would
you advise a woman like me two kids
divorced
what would i advise you yeah when it
comes to dating i would say you probably
want to date a man with kids who's a
little bit older okay how would how do
you 30 yeah
looking like the 40s after 45 range 40
25 yeah because older men who have
already established themselves yeah
older men have already established
themselves they have no problem with a
woman like that it's the younger men
like a 30 year old man i wouldn't date a
30 year old man even if i didn't so you
dated someone older yeah okay well then
you should be around now i'm just asking
out curiosity yeah like you should be
okay because older men don't mind taking
that and i'm saying if you're looking
for somebody your age or younger they're
just not going to be would you be okay
with an average earner so a guy that
makes i don't know what's average here i
don't really like talking about money
because it stresses me out but um i
don't like
i think it's very selfish i would say
this i think it's selfish for a woman to
expect a man who is on a certain money
and she's on a certain money to give her
the lifestyle she has already i think
it's very selfish because for example
say a guy is on 30k since there's a
number everyone likes to use and you're
not on that and your outgoings for
example is like 4k you're now expecting
him and say you agree to do 50 50. that
50 50 is gonna hit him a lot long more
than you so i just feel like i just i
would like to put myself environments
that there's no stress
would you change your lifestyle for a
man i say no now but if i fall in love i
probably would
but i may resent you for it or feel
uncertain
yeah i mean
no i'm people
then no no no no no no no no no because
you see us women when we fall in love
sometimes all of a sudden a is not after
a is not b all of a sudden is f but when
i'm telling you that women change their
mind
i never said i never when she said i
never said that we don't but i said that
when we fall in love we accept i said i
said women date potential
like when you're in love you turn around
and say you know what
he's earning 30k now
in a few years i can i can change him i
can support him i can direct him into
how he can earn more i'm not doing that
and then a lot of women not say yourself
but then a lot of women have children
with those men and get really pissed off
at those men and you blame yourself yeah
no but they blame them they have oh my
baby that is this is like say you knew
that guy was a dead people with him
it's like it's like future like is it on
future is it on the baby mamas that keep
sleeping with him yeah
it doesn't change the fact he is that
yeah but you've chosen to have a child
with him so then you're happy
in control of birth men have no say in
who gets born so yeah i think with that
control like we should adopt more
responsibility in who we sleep with than
men because yeah we're in control
and that's what we're saying earlier
like to the the the decision to get
pregnant
is on the woman it's not on the man like
i said you have you have the access he
has to access your body if it's not
great you once you're once your body is
accessed right you have the decision
whether or not you want to keep the baby
after the baby's born you have the the
decision whether or not you want to put
the baby up for adoption or get cha it's
all on you
but now that decision would have existed
or been if that joint decision was if
you hadn't if a woman hadn't opened her
legs yeah i know can i ask you a
question sorry can i ask you a question
because women women control access to
sex men control access to relationships
if you were if you were in a
relationship and you didn't want to have
a child would you rely on the woman to
um to use contraception
yourself
um because i don't trust no [ __ ]
that's just me like i don't trust no one
like i'm always out for protecting
myself good okay do you know what i mean
that's just me a lot but the thing is
but i'm the same type of type of person
who wants to put a burglar alarm on
their house some people don't you get
what i'm saying so
if you didn't if you didn't strap up and
she got pregnant would you think you
have a right to ask her to get an um
abortion
yeah um if i didn't strap up you didn't
want the child she wanted a child but
you didn't strap up so i wanted the
child no you did it i didn't want the
child but you didn't show up but she did
and she expressed it to you
bro you put yourself in a sticky one
there so i can say you put yourself in a
sticky one do you believe in um since we
have the right to control our bodies
that men should have the right to
control their wallet so if there's an
unplanned pregnancy there should be able
to have like a financial abortion the
same way we can have an abortion an
unplanned pregnancy you slept with me
and you didn't strap out so no no
you slept with each other yeah yeah they
both
needed yeah so they both they both made
the irresponsible decision right to have
sex that's on both of them but then when
she's pregnant she can say do i want to
be a mother yes or no abortion no
abortion so then should men have the
right to say you know what do i want to
be a father yes or no financial like i
can sign off my rights i can not i don't
owe any child support i always say in
that situation where neither of you
strapped up and you fall pregnant you
have a conversation with the guy he
doesn't want to keep it and you do you
you've made that decision to solely look
after the child so you shouldn't expect
anything from him okay right so you see
if you see if you both see is he in this
situation where you both
didn't use
contraception
like i said to people women are the one
that's going to be left with the shitty
end of the stick when it comes to that
right so women are going to have to
learn who to have sex with and
so you could you could have sex with a
guy who's a deadbeat and he could say
you know what i'm just going to go and
roar
you're the one that's going to be left
with that you know you're 100 you know
what i'm saying so if you're the one
left of it then
like i said this is why i always tell
you everybody take responsibility for
themselves
i'm a big believer of if
when it comes to having kids i feel like
it should all you should have the kids
when two parties want it
i know this sounds mad yeah women are in
control of their body and everything but
if
i'm pregnant
hypothetically speaking if me and you
were about to have if me and you are
sleeping each other and whatever happens
whether we're using protection because
it does happen sometimes you need
protection you still get pregnant
if i wanted it and you didn't i wouldn't
keep it if you wanted it and i didn't i
shouldn't keep it still i feel like when
it comes to children
um
it should be one about yeah it's just so
unfair on that child because
what you have to understand which which
i give you guys to an extent is you're
potentially bringing out a problematic
child yeah do you understand so i agree
a woman a woman is into and i said
that's why i say that i feel like us
women one of our biggest problems is we
don't realize the power we have
and if we realize the power we have our
emotions get in the way so much we don't
take power for some of the things that
we should take power for and because men
are so large what do you mean by that
like just
powering the way our life goes okay yeah
like in how we live our lives like for
instance look at me i'm a single mom
with two kids right some of the issues i
had with my ex-husband i'd seen it
before we got married if i had fair
enough i was young and all of that kind
of stuff maybe i wasn't asking i was
real 23 when i got married right but he
was basically the only man i knew i'd
been with him since i was 16 right so
technically i did things the right way
and all of that stuff but he was in the
same age no he was a bit older like
three years older but if i was
exposed maybe if my dad was even there
do you understand like maybe i would
have probably
not got married because my dad would
have probably seen things as a man that
my mother couldn't see my mum was just
you know when i say us women we we
behave on emotions right mom's just
happy that i'm happy you know what i
mean like my mom's probably asking are
you sure you want to get married maybe
she had doubts yeah that's why she's
asking but she doesn't want to hurt me
whereas my dad would have been like no
do you feel
good relationship with my my dad now and
one hundred percent my dad's meet my the
bad guy 100 i think men do vet in terms
and better than women because men know
the ones they want to sleep with and the
ones that's wife women we mix up the
ones that we should just keep for
sleeping the ones that are our husbands
material no we predate potential we know
we shouldn't they married them but we're
just like yeah wouldn't could have
should have yeah but this is why
men well but then
like a guy a guy can't have nothing and
women will go for them because like he
has to have something usually he's tall
and attractive or has game or something
but don't you think most of the
marriages that go a bit left is because
they've dated them from young because i
think the ones that go
yeah so it's i have this here actually
it's like um
women
under a certain age that haven't lived
with a guy of the highest chance of like
a happy marriage they haven't lived with
a guy yeah i haven't it's actually high
so if you're dating you just don't live
together um let me pull it up one second
um i think yeah when it comes to vetting
i think men are better vets yeah i think
and i think that's down to
the emotional side okay women women
married in their mid-20s have the lowest
rate of divorce i got divorced only
we're not talking about you we're not
talking about them
only 30 of the women had um um actually
i don't know what stat that was higher
body count is linked to depression um
only 30
these statistics might be long
i don't know what this i wrote this one
doesn't make sense but yeah higher body
counts depression women in their mid-20s
at the lowest grades
you know it's funny because you say that
you don't think i'm submissive and all
of that stuff which is fine
but um i feel like if when i do get
married again i feel like my marriage
will work better because because of what
you've learned yeah
talking to your mic sorry darling i i'm
more acceptant of my mistakes i feel
like when when people remarry the reason
why it doesn't work is because they've
not accepted the mistakes they make you
see for marriage to work
or for it to fail both parties have gone
wrong
whether you want to accept it or not
even whatever it is except for violence
obviously but
i believe both parties have gone wrong
like i i've accepted i know where i went
wrong in my marriage and i don't she's
shaking her head over there
oh okay and i i i know where i've gone
wrong he may have more fault than i did
right but i still know the bits i
attributed to in that marriage
so i now know that okay whatever i get
into
i need to carry myself a certain way i
need to speak a certain way i need to so
long as i do my pit my bit my part right
he i can't guarantee he will do his part
right i can't predict what a guy will do
but also based on how i vet and choose
now
i find it hard to believe i'll get
divorced again because i'm not even in a
rush to get married i just want to do it
right this time
so you don't think you'll get divorced
again i mean you never said you never
know you never never say never yet but i
get you okay so you feel like you've
learned from your mistakes
you were shaking your head yeah i don't
think um divorce is based on two people
doing something wrong i think there's
loads of marriages where
one person's just decided they just
don't want their marriage anymore and
it's not because of anything internal it
might really yeah it might actually be i
actually know one personal that the
woman just didn't want the marriage
anymore because she didn't love him
right i don't know
but even if it was because she didn't
love him this was the same man that you
married yeah if he hasn't changed that's
you know he hasn't changed
she probably she probably married her
second choice
yeah that's usually what happens is the
girl like they're getting closer to the
age where they need to have kids they
marry the first guy that'll take them
maybe and then and then they can't get
that x out of their head so they leave
to try to find something just so what
are the statistics again is it women
that leave marriages more yeah women
women leave marriages 70 to 80 percent
of the time if they're college educated
it's 90. yeah
okay
and i personally believe that's down to
the fact that women have been sold a
hollywood version disney dream of what a
relationship is i do think social media
has confused people um i'm definitely an
example of that but obviously i've woken
up i feel like um
you look at social media and you see
these people are in love or when you see
people getting married but you don't
remember they've probably kissed so many
frogs they've gone through so many
heartbreaks i've gone through so many
things so now i don't that's why i said
i don't really go with statistics i just
go with what my reality is and what i've
learned and what i've deemed as wrong
and right okay i want to show you guys
something look at
the this is the divorce rate
this is oral contraceptive sorry this is
the divorce rate and this is oral
contraceptive use
of the views so so basically
so basically the pill is what in my
opinion broke marriages because like
look how similar those are like
literally as soon as the pill was
introduced people started getting
divorced yeah it's interesting because
you think
definitely from my own experience like
my parents they stayed together because
they had a child
and i think that there's a lot of
families out there that stay together
because of children yeah and it can
cause it potentially does cause like
other potential deeper rooted issues and
longer down the line as well but i think
there are less and less people that are
willing to
yeah are willing to put themselves in a
marriage where they have to stay
together for the sake of the child and
then more and more people are choosing
to
look at what is a healthy environment
for a child now in a different whole way
so now that's probably you know with
this whole now with maybe the freedom of
con that contraception does
give for women to make choices
to to test out their options and to try
their options it's like now
women have that choice to not stay in a
marriage that doesn't fulfill them
wouldn't it wouldn't it be better to
like work it out like figure out how to
get along with the guy right because
because to me it's like what is it isn't
duty more important than happiness so
can i just say something before i'm a
mother i am a woman and if i'm not happy
as a woman i probably wouldn't be happy
as a mother yeah don't isn't it about
your kids happiness though not yours no
because my kids
like a human being and i'm a human being
and just because i have had a child i
take responsibility of my child doesn't
mean that i do not deserve happiness
right but i'm saying i'm saying like
like
to me once you have a kid it's not about
you anymore it's not about your
happiness like that should come so it's
about my kids safety and my kids
environment well i don't i don't i don't
know you're personal no but i'm saying
in general all mothers i think no matter
what you are a woman first you i was me
before i became a mother but i'm sorry
my role just changed but i'm i'm saying
like wouldn't you say that it's not the
majority of women that are being abused
because i think that's what you're into
you said my safety no i said my my
child's safety my child's environment
right what is important to me but
shouldn't your child's happiness make
you happy i think not necessarily
because i'm
still a human being i'm still there were
things that made me happy prior to
having my job happiness over
family duty like family duty what is
family duty like okay
happy environment okay my parents their
30th my parents 30th wedding anniversary
was two days ago let's go yeah yeah
shout out mom and dad but like there
there were times where they didn't like
each other and they weren't happy but
like judy was you know what i'm gonna
put the family before my personal
happiness
okay so i come i've come i've seen my
mum married and a single mom right and
i've also been married and become a
single mom
and when i was married and miserable and
depressed and all of that kind of stuff
i wasn't an attentive and good mother
but now that i am happy
right and i'm in a better space i'm so
attentive to my kids like i'm so i put
so much effort and time into my kids
it's unbelievable i know when
something's going wrong you see when the
mind is not at peace you look past and
dismiss it don't pick up on things so so
question do you
do you think your kids would say the
same thing
like what would they think they would
prefer the the parents apart yeah the
the kids may not prefer the parents
apart because they love both yeah but if
they were to look at the um us
individually and how especially if they
were to look at me individually and
compare me to then and now they'll
prefer me do you think that happiness is
a choice their happiness no do you think
your happiness you have some
responsibility for how happy you are
yeah because i told you based on the
choices i've made
no i'm i'm talking about like like
to me like i could be in a shitty i like
i've been i've been in a relationship
where i wasn't happy before but like
to me like your happiness is a choice
like i can choose in a day if i want to
look at things like with a good attitude
or i want to be unhappy so if you're
saying that if you're if your
preferences or things you like or how
you like to be treated in a relationship
and you're not being treated like that
you can choose to still be happy
yeah okay that's interesting did you
choose to stay happy in your
relationship no i never cared
yeah what do you mean well you have you
weren't happy but did you why didn't you
choose to be happy in that relationship
why why didn't i choose why i was happy
that's what i'm saying you said you
weren't happy no i'm saying sorry i
thought you meant did you did you choose
to stay like are you still with him i
thought that was the question
no i'm what i'm saying is that i i was
still a happy person in that
relationship
and like my my family still did you guys
live together no see when you're living
together it's very different imagine
someone is breaking your heart or
hurting you and you have to see them
every day and play house in front of
your kids and you go into your room and
you cry and everything and you're
thinking i have to make this work
because of my children i have to make
and you just get inside
no but that's how it that's how it leads
though when when you get to the point
from somewhere it starts from somewhere
i'm saying
the example you're giving that's not
extreme that's not exactly that's not
even this is not even extreme this is
that word
so you're in a relationship you're
saying
you're saying there's a
i don't know majority of women are in
relationships when they leave
it's because they've been going through
that time yeah yeah you don't just get
up and leave trust me and a lot of women
that stay in their relationships and
their marriages stop the cat
because the statistics don't like okay
what is this decision okay so when you
look at the reasons for divorce right
and look there's like top 10 reasons for
that on that list you will have finance
you have finances you will have adultery
um
yeah that adult you'll be on the list
you will have the fact that uh the
person fell out of love
um people grew apart
uh
when you talk about abuse
abuse is on the list but it's not as
high up as people assume it is and
people and and i think a lot of the time
people assume oh the reason why she left
the relationship is because there was
abuse going on no a lot of the time she
had an abuse because she felt like she
fell out of love with a guy do you know
what i really question the kind of
people you speak to because a lot of
women a lot of women i know do not leave
because of abuse they stay because
they're scared to leave yeah and a lot
of women do leave because of finances
i've no offense if you're cheating
you're clearly not happy so unhappiness
is part of it if you're if you grow
apart you're not happy
like there are so many things to say i'm
not happy in this relationship do you
think that
when you say and you stand at the altar
i'm not a religious person but when you
say till death do us part right for
instance and then you file for divorce
because i wasn't happy do you think
that's like a good thing yeah but people
use that's what she's trying to say
people use the term i'm not happy you
see women we like to pretend no some
women will not tell you why they're not
happy because it's embarrassing
i mean yeah so yeah no no not
embarrassing because it's pathetic it's
embarrassing because it's sad
right
it's so easy just blankets stay here
even in a form you see us women it's not
just in front of people it's also to
ourselves it's embarrassing sometimes we
lie to ourselves it's better to just say
i'm not happy so when you're filling out
these statistics you think people
there's another thing because people
don't like it always yeah you think
people don't land
you have to base it off of something
so so like the way we do it is when we
have facts to back it up we can base it
off of something where on the other hand
you're just basing it off of what you
feel yeah which is fair but also people
lie on statistics because you got that
statistics from people right okay but if
you have women
okay okay question if you have different
stats that were taken in different
cities by different organizations and
they're all saying the same thing do you
think we cannot conclude
i've accepted that that's how you guys
do you think that's fine but what i'm
saying is when people leave
relationships
as a as a woman no woman
wants to be a single mom
i don't think there's women that's out
there that goes into the marriage and
says yes
i want to talk to you next time
you know like when i
go wherever they choose it yeah you
choose i'm not we have we are now in an
environment where we have the freedom to
make decisions and you say no one wants
to be a single mum no i don't think
someone gets married
there are women that don't mind being
yeah you see what happened when it came
to drake when the woman tried to do the
whole thing
oh she was very happy to be in a single
moment about being married when you when
you get married and you have kids no one
gets into that marriage saying i'm going
to leave for a woman to i think no but
[ __ ] gets hard and girls give up yeah i
think women get sold
and kill themselves yeah but nobody so
women get told a hollywood version of
what a relationship is right and what
happens is that when when they get into
relationship they realize it's actually
hard work like women have been living
have been sold hollywood rom-coms disney
this is what a relationship should be
like this is what your relationship
goals should be they've been sold that
for like decades right and then what
happened i like the mail thank you
yeah i feel like a lot of men get
depressed and killed
a lot of the responsibility is being put
like what i'm hearing is like the women
the women do everything yeah because
they're the ones filing for divorce 80
of the time it's not the men which is
fine but what i'm saying is the men have
a part to play in this as well we're not
talking about that so can we talk which
is what what what parts play what do you
mean maybe they're being abusive maybe
they're cheating you know it's like you
said earlier if a lady women women and
men cheat at the same rates sorry can i
just say one thing with in in align with
what you're about to say so women
and this is why i always say with
statistics
you see men what would you use no no i
get it no no no i get it don't get me
wrong i get why you get it right but the
reason why i'm so on the fence about it
is because men don't like to file for
divorce because they don't like to
believe they failed at something where
women are okay with it i know so no no
men are not failing no no no no no no no
uh i'll give you an example
[Applause]
a lot of them get into like financial
ruin or they can't see their kids so
they kill themselves okay it's about the
kids but what i was about it really is
nobody really is
no it's not no listen the suicide rate
of a man who's been separated from his
children
is at times four times higher he's four
times more likely to to commit suicide
if he's been separated from his wife and
children okay i can understand that so
so it impacts so when you say are white
men um uh divorcing it's because men
know what it is to keep this thing
together and when a man keeps it
together he understands what it is he's
not trying to let it go because he knows
that he needs that
also also also that you're the
married have the lowest these are the
levels of the divorce the green line is
slower it's lower than single can i
speak because i haven't spoken but i
feel like i think what we're failing to
realize is men a men aren't getting
support within society right so a lot of
that support falls onto the woman
so now if a man is unhappy in a
situation and he's doing something maybe
he's been mentally abusive maybe he's
been like it may not be just physical a
woman has to take that on
from my perspective right i've never
been married i don't have children
whatever but in my romanticized way of
looking at things like this yeah
a woman is supposed to
look after be a nurturer that's what i
my picture my picture is from scripture
like proverbs 21 woman you're supposed
to have that but if a man isn't getting
that mental support if a man you know if
a woman wants to sit down and
communicate with her man but the man
doesn't want to you know her spouse
doesn't wanna you know yeah so question
do you do you think the majority of men
are abusive or verbally abusive no i
don't but i feel like you'd say that's a
minority right well i don't i don't know
i haven't seen the statistics but my
point is i feel like men as a whole
suppress a lot whether they're being
abused or not sometimes it could just be
a lack of communication whether they're
being abused
or you say
because i like even even the fact that
you can't say that's not the majority of
men you don't think that's offensive to
men that will that you can't you can't
that you can't say like like in good
confidence the majority of men are not
abusive probably but okay
probably but i feel like yeah i feel
like i'm just trying to paint a full
picture because we're talking a lot
about the women's perspective and the
women's failures i want to kind of
highlight what a man's failure might be
in this situation because we're not
looking at that it's kind of like hold
on hold on hold on we're kind of looking
at the reason why that is is because men
are not the ones saying i give up
a man wouldn't say
why do we just assume men are the
problem no when i say a man is the
problem the woman is not happy with him
right men a man most men will not and
i've said this already most men will not
go for foul for divorce are women a lot
of women have um said all right i don't
want to do this right because men stick
through things when it gets tough
women give up but men have outlets of
doing other things
what do you mean okay so if if i'm
leaving this marriage because let's say
it's a situation where the man is the
pro like there's a problem within our
marriage and it's me that's voicing out
what my issue is right is it cheating or
abuse
whatever it is right because i don't i
feel like everyone keeps talking about
china there's other problems out there
than cheating and abuse but whatever if
so long as there's a problem and a voice
to you there is a problem right i'm the
one with the problem so you don't
necessarily have an issue and if you're
not listening to me and we're not
getting anywhere i'm definitely going to
be the one that's going to leave because
i'm the one with the problem you are
okay with doing whatever you're doing
and living the way we are so you're not
going to ask for a divorce because
you're asking for the guy to change
right right and be different than he is
but like part of growing with someone is
just realizing they have negative traits
and that's how they are where they are
like
i'll give you an example my mom for
years right she has asked my dad to be
more considerate of like planning right
like like he always just does whatever
he wants to do
i'm giving you a small example because i
don't really feel like telling you the
deep dark okay yeah yeah which is fine
yeah but but i'm saying like like she
could focus on that problem and say i
have a problem i'm so unhappy or she can
just learn to live with it like part of
it's just learning to live without
something can i just ask something if he
cheats on
um on the marriage should i say
is that valid enough for her to say she
wants to leave yeah she it depends
okay
because there's a problem where women
don't sleep with their husbands okay so
if you're not so so so i'm saying i'm
saying that if she asked me if i would
advise it that's why i'm saying it
depends so on one thing it's like if
you're not sleeping with him he's gonna
get it from somewhere else but he's
stepping out on the mabbage yeah
i don't think it's okay but i have a
little bit of empathy and understanding
i've talked to guys that tell me they
haven't had sex in two years like it's
been two years what do you expect to
have but if she cheats as well because
he's not sleeping with her is that okay
is that you do you have empathy for the
woman as well if if if she cheats yeah
and he's not sleeping with for two years
yeah actually yeah
wow i'm thinking about why is she not
sleeping with him why don't we okay so
this is not a dissection
this is a mindset thing because to me it
like like sex is a duty yeah sorry can i
just uh
so um you see that one i just believe as
if you're my man and you're my husband
i just believe if it's possible before
you leave the house every day i'm gonna
give it to you i i need so long as you
desire me and you make me feel desired
i'm going to make you feel desired and
part of your feelings
sorry unless i'm a bit confused because
i'm like why is the woman withholding
sex there's a yeah there has to be a
reason i i can i that's with me being
married i can have sex with my husband
even if we're fighting especially if
we're still if we're still together not
and the fight we're fighting i know i
still want to be with you sex is not off
the cards there's no point it's like
then can we look at maybe where maybe
the man may want to open up about
something that he's going through why
the woman's not do you know what i'm
saying why does it have to automatically
automatically go to like okay so the
woman is the woman's issue it's a
woman's issue okay she's like we're
holding do we do we
do we create environments for our men to
feel like they can come to us to talk
about their problems yeah i'm sorry but
that excuse of the the man's not getting
sex they're so whack i'm sorry because
there are men that get sex all the time
and still cheat on their wives so that's
that's a really weak excuse that's my
minority so that's some problem that's a
minority though
the majority of men can't cheat the
majority of men don't have the options
to cheat okay like if you're if a man
cheating like top 30 maybe
if a man if a man cheats on his wife
and she and he's getting sex is that
enough for her to leave the marriage in
your opinion are there kids
whichever i i personally think like sex
is different for men and for women so i
think if a man cheats he could like men
will have sex with a hole in the wall no
i don't i don't i have them in fails no
no but i'm saying personal like i
personally i think if there's kids you
should do everything you can to make it
work and i i would try to make it work
okay but is it i'm saying you personally
would try and make it work yeah but if a
woman did leave do you think that's
justifiable
yeah in some cases i think i think
sometimes like if something like that
was hard for you to me do you no because
because a lot of times you're trying to
like get me in a gotcha moment but i'm
saying no but i'm saying i'm saying i
don't think i don't but no because
because because okay you don't let me
finish and it's kind of rude yeah so i'm
saying even even in a situation in that
situation like i think if he brings home
an std that's disrespectful if he's
screwing all around town and everyone
knows that's disrespectful like i think
for the most part like
that like again when they're kids you
should do everything you can to work it
out so if there's no other kid if he's
not embarrassing you like i think you
should try to work it out
if men realize that women are very
emotional
but if you realize that then don't you
realize how that's going to deeply cut
your wife
it could be on both parts though it
could be if she's cheated i think a man
should do everything he can to make it
work don't you think
why why not if there's kids if there's
kids right we don't work like that why
because all we can see
is you having sex with someone else
we're not even thinking about anything
else
you won't even be thinking about your
child but wow listen you might be
thinking about your child
saying would you be thinking about your
childhood i'm saying don't understand
things by saying would you
think about your child we've said men
and women are not eating no you you
never thought about the child because i
cheated but if you agree i didn't think
about that
it hurts it hurts the audio quality if
you're all going at once so why don't
you go ahead i'm genuinely asking if she
cheated on you she didn't think about
the child the moment she cheated but if
you cheated on her she needs to think
about the child to stay
what i'm saying is
men and women cheating is different when
a woman cheats there is a there is a
question of paternity should she get
pregnant if a man cheats on you there's
no that said
you've never seen a mori show mm-hmm
where a guy's where a woman's like am i
the mommy okay yeah you've never seen it
definitely and you know why you've never
seen it is because when menchie and when
women cheat it's two totally different
things because when women cheat a man
can be on maury like
however i don't know
however
i understand i completely understand
however
legally
marriage
adultery is adultery they didn't put a
sex on it they didn't say when a woman
cheats is a different type of adultery
when a man cheats is a different type
adultery is adultery if you step out on
the marriage and you cheat it warrants
what about what about till death do us
part what about when god said you can
leave based on adultery yeah let's not
let's not don't make it
just to validate your point like this
let's do it
like to me like do you don't think your
word means something what was that
is he so if he's going to cheat what
does his what he's always a man's vow
that he does
means nothing men and women are
different because i don't know
100 but if you're answering to the most
high then it's not me they answered this
isn't a religious show
hey one at a time apologies please
ladies one at a time bear with me
sorry
can i just say something please no one
should you know men and women are not
equal
we just have to accept it once we accept
that men and women are not equal life
will just become a little bit easier not
that it's okay i'm not saying these
things are okay but once we accept that
men and women are not equal i feel like
as women will be able to channel things
a lot differently but i do think there's
i do think though men take the piss and
take the liberty on what they know they
can get away with that's [ __ ]
because if men and women are not the
same yeah that's fine yeah but it's the
same vowel we talk yeah i'm not
disputing it
if it's a case of we need to accept that
then please legally or wherever they
should change the vowels it's not let
men say different [ __ ] then all right
though but did
man cheating is him spending his
resources on another girl because we
have different mating strategies no i'm
saying you're talking about in terms of
men are different from women but i'm
saying it's the same vows we take
regardless so if you are a man and you
can yeah exactly
no one should cheat on anyone so if you
are a man and you are saying if i cheat
you don't need to leave please do a
caveat in the vowels like all right bro
and that's fair enough because
you know me and new contracts right
sorry to digress i just wanted to ask
like do you think you men are honest
when it comes in your relationships
about sex
in what way would you like how you guys
feel about the sex you're receiving and
women lie as well about that man what do
you feel no i don't mean about the
pleasure i mean are you guys honest
about the fact that you're not being
pleased because i feel like us women are
not honest a lot of the time that we're
not necessarily being pleased but are
you i don't think men are honest and i
think that's why a lot of the time they
cheat more as well do you think it takes
time because they can do do you think
that it takes do you think it takes that
much to sexually satisfy a guy yeah i
think you're going to be making some
noise that he's not feeling no you can
be doing it a way he doesn't i think i
think it depends on the guy's experience
and whether he's had sex with a woman
multiple times enough to coach her
but really if he's had like multiple
experiences where he's been with like
girls from amsterdam the red district
like he's probably had his mind blown
and it will be quite tough for his woman
and then also there's a level of like
respect that a man will have for his
wife or his partner that he won't want
to disrespect
or he won't want to disrespect his wife
yeah the same way he's gone oh why is it
i never understand that
yeah i've heard that and i feel like if
you're married like there should be no
boundaries
anything should go
you're not ready to delve into the man's
mind
you see i feel like if you're married to
as a wife yeah i believe it's my duty to
please you i should be your cheerleader
your number one fan and part of that is
making you feel like a king in the
bedroom so i'm going to ask you i'm
going to ask you what is it you like i
will try i will be honest i don't like
the idea start saying some real
outlandish [ __ ] you're gonna be like
what you want what you know she had a
[ __ ] on me and stuff like that you know
what but i will try and i feel like you
should respect the fact that i'm
actively trying to try these things but
i feel like you're not saying anything
then i think that's a bit different
now i hear you i'm just saying like
men's mind's gonna be dark
but what if you're watching
so where did where does the mind go i
don't get it i don't know
i'm not incriminating myself let me in
on the secret the guys are laughing back
there they already know what's
what's going on yeah is that based on
videos you've seen as well like does
that has that tainted your view on what
re real success is i plead the fifth oh
wow
but it's not fair
he wanted to say something no i just
said let's let's get it oh my gosh you
turn my mic off let's be honest like
let's be honest let's be real that's how
we're going to build bridges
especially in our course the one thing
men have learned
is that when a woman says tell me the
truth is not to tell the truth
that's the one thing that we've learned
that is a lot that is a lot that's kind
of true
but when it comes to when it comes to
the bedroom thing i i want him to
you know you can tell your woman what
you like but still be prepared i want
men to lie to you trust me you as a
woman like we trust me you don't want a
man to say but do you know i think
because of your lying as well it
suppresses how you feel you feel like
you're being suppressed
uh i can live with that maybe but you
can live with that so what would you
cheat as a married man no i wouldn't
because i understand that it would it
could potentially destroy the nuclear
family so is it because you guys want
threesomes there's those are the kind of
things that you're saying hey not all of
us aren't no i'm trying to figure out
what kind of food that is so
a man will have like fantasies that he
may want to explore
hey i don't know
you're trying to get specific yeah we're
trying to be vague i'm trying to be
vague we're trying to be vague he
understands that these specifics may
cause major problems in the relationship
so let's say he wants a threesome yeah
and you're saying oh i'd be on that cool
he now invites you over to do it and you
meet the girl
now
you in the moment dynamics change you go
absolutely not like i can't be having
this i can't believe you
you flipped the script and it causes
your marriage to break down because he
allowed something that was sacred
between you and him to into the in the
house how can you fix that yeah but why
does it have to involve someone else why
can't it be you fantasies you want to do
and it's just but that's his fantasies
i'm just i'm just kidding guys just
don't tell him
don't worry about it leave him leave too
and and he doesn't know if he's honest
if you're going to be like what the why
would you want that like yeah
like it's too much of a risk for guys
what if your woman tells you some mad
fantasy she wants to do though
i say you've got to figure out whether
it's a trap or not listen okay anecdotal
piece of evidence i was when i was in
relationship i my partner said to me oh
it was it was my birthday coming up and
she said do you want to freeze him and i
was like
[Laughter]
i'm sorry what
and she was like yeah it's your birthday
when i was like
this is a trap do you think i'm stupid
like do you think i'm stupid because
they wanna a lot of time women wanna
test to see if you're looking elsewhere
i'm like listen and uh stop stop
stupidness because i understand women do
that i think a lot of women are bisexual
men don't know that wait that could be
that too i think a lot of women want to
dabble in those things and i just don't
know how to speak for yourself
i'm not saying that i'm talking about me
but i always just try i'm just curious
as to why you think it's always a trap
i'm just being curious about it because
we don't trust y'all because that you
will actually say like i said you would
say something
knowing knowing what you're actually
saying it for okay you know the desired
you're like oh so he's
sorry that's what he meant when he's do
you women are too i said women have a
superpower and men have a superpower
men's power is their actual physical
power right that's how we've always got
things done done women's superpower is
manipulation
right that's how they get things done
they know the right questions to ask the
way in which to ask it and the best time
in which to ask it right so we as men we
understand well i understand i'm saying
you guys need to understand that too
it's like so they use that to get what
they want so i'm just like nah i'm just
not going to be
you ain't going to pull that one on me
so fair enough
do you know i see y'all okay i see you
do you not think that
women are
actually conditioned to protect them
protect the male ego in that within that
probably
yeah i think a lot of women do protect
the male ego they the male ego can be
fragile you know i mean i think a lot of
women do know that so um as much as you
might say you want to protect the male
ego there's a lot of men that say they
just want to protect you in general so a
lot of the times they'll lie to you
they'll tell you that you don't look fat
you know what i mean when they know that
you do like they'll they're lying to you
to protect you they'll tell you oh no
she was just a friend because they know
that you might overthink about the fact
that this woman has do you know what i
mean like there's certain things that
men do to protect you and there's
certain things that women do to protect
men definitely i agree would you want
your mom to tell you guys that you were
fat
yeah yeah mm-hmm
honestly i would i would
i'll
say that but then i'll be like so you
didn't see the pounds
i wouldn't want the blunt honestly yeah
yeah i wouldn't want the blunt honestly
so how would you want to say chabawaba
no i would want to i would want him to
tell me like is it when i'm fat finish
you'll be like oh baby you're fat didn't
you see the group no no you already saw
the growth no you know you don't already
know
then they ask do you think i look fat
you already know you do you know that's
why you're awesome
yeah but you don't notice when it's the
gradually you just notice when you're
there yeah all of a sudden will
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna read super
chats for a second we got a 50 super
chat
let's go
okay um da swoovius can you still
receive your bit degree what does bit
stand for
i don't know okay can you still receive
your bit degree even if you get
overwhelmed and quit before the duration
the irony of modern women is they
comprehend
is they comprehend that work and effort
goes into everything else except when it
comes to spending your life with someone
cis so something um i can't pronounce
that love the show 90 free topaz a man
can burp and a girl would never sleep
with him ata patrice o'neill would say
it would say you your loss
say if she cheats um 90 free topaz two
panels no balls no opinions listen to
sarah 90 free to pay panel is reactive
staying silent and they have nothing um
kai for hunter modern women go into
relationships not knowing what it
actually takes they don't know
themselves and how to play a role that's
conducive for a functioning relationship
just a message from sees so t thank you
for the sticker
justin maple i would like the question
to be posed to these women
can a man decide to leave you and not
pay pay alimony because he is unhappy
with you
that's actually we'll go back to that in
a second i'm going to read the rest 90
free topaz men's duty over one's
oneself woman themselves inc over
inconvenience family god pets good
financial choices healthy choices gym
future generation not all but most
wendell coven 9.3.9 billion women in the
world in the end they speak for all ata
men beware of these women they will jada
pink at you the way they speak of
happiness justin maple thank you for the
super chat um nightingale
congratulations pearl's parents but
still get that man a camera 90 free
topic
let's go
ladies forgive your mom and return your
to your father k to the swiss the moment
the child is born but you but
the moment the child is born your wants
mean zero you're now last in everything
and they can't accept that then don't
have children 90 free to pay ladies
listen to patrice o'neil if you want a
man dragon stallion one zero zero one to
the ladies on the couch please do not
listen to what the green with the woman
in the green has been saying your chance
of being wifed up when the lady green
and the green will forever be divorced
hip-hop opponents men should be allowed
to sign out of parenting
responsibilities just like a sperm donor
if the same if it is the same time
window women can have an abortion
nightingale my wallet my money so get
that man a camera let's let's go
dragon stallion one zero zero one you
can't quantify potential but you can
quantify history which is why men look
at a woman's past and a woman looks at a
man's future
das token e30 love for a woman is really
lost just super goofy dash token love is
for poor people dallas token e30
according to the stats blended families
don't work 90 free topaz green dress if
you had no [ __ ] how would you keep it
sorry i can't say it
i'm sorry sorry i mean okay if you had
no well then how would you keep a man um
i and mac in regard to body count
doesn't mean that you can please me girl
would she say a virgin or someone with a
body count is 20 is more able to solve
the rubik's cube
90 free top remember you need three men
ever for
pearl remember you need three men for
every one woman the girls here are just
gonna squawk like parrots and to deflect
not all squawk when i'm not like that um
won't stay with her because she isn't
teachable soretta bass green dress be
like no stat because i'm special dragon
stallion one zero zero one woman green
if he's teachable yes i bet she refuses
to be teachable herself jazz token most
single moms live in poverty stats say so
serretta bass if a woman wants to stop
you from seeing your child let it go i
promise she hates you more than she
loves the kid in the government and it's
against you men go men off themselves
because of this like a lot let it go daz
token why not plan parenting before the
kid comes out gas token when we in the
state say don't put a wagon before the
horse why start planning on parenting
before the kids are here it makes no
sense anonymous co-parenting incentives
of women's
mindset that our children will be fine
after she chooses self-happiness over
her kids men focus on building and see
your kids when you can same as if you
were married but matt butcher men are
dropping out of marriage like flies for
a reason the root is misguided feminism
renato jill the legal system is all
about women i paid child support for
over 14 years and gave my ex over three
hundred thousand dollars tax free i see
my kids less than four times a month it
sounds fair so norris dicks that's what
i'm saying um no so no single dads no
short men no virgins any chance modern
ladies might judge a man on his actual
character jack i wish i could slap angel
in the mouth um i think that was who's
angel
i don't know well maybe it's a comment i
don't like it i don't know um so
blackest panther get
ish a damn step stool already orbital
punch matthew 19 9 i say to you whoever
divorces his wife except on the grounds
of sexual immorality and marries another
commits adultery by law god amen by law
god and man a woman can divorce her
husband if he cheats dyslevias can you
okay that's the last one because that we
read the one before i think it needs to
wrap up now don't we yeah it's getting
kind of late
all right um if we
goodness gracious thank you very much
everyone for joining as a matter of fact
yeah thanks for coming in this heat yeah
like guys if you see us sweating it's
because this is the hottest thing this
is why we got to sign up for memberships
get us air conditioning
i'm moving in the fall and i really want
to pay for a place with air conditioning
and our memberships help support the
rent so yeah all right closing thoughts
let's go around yeah go around say where
the people can find you any last
thoughts that you have
oh okay um
instagram maxi
underscore jay
um
what's my closing thoughts
i don't know if you guys put me on the
spot
um
basically what was it what was the
original question it was a baby daddy
baby daddy
i don't really have any clothes
my instagram and my website is at fenina
moore
my closing thoughts is i clearly don't
know much about
men
i clearly don't know much about men so
um yeah i'm open to learning i feel like
i need to do a lot more learning so yeah
go ahead
so hi so handle is limitless.her you can
find me on instagram
um my closing thoughts are
actually
i feel that
in this day and age
we're
you can really choose to do whatever you
want to do i think you can have a
thriving
uh i think you could be a single mother
and you could be thriving and find a new
partner or or not or you can
choose not to if you want to and that's
the beauty of
the day this day and age
okay
cool great oh sorry um
instagram uh gracie bakery um
i don't have any closing thoughts before
they insult me
um i'm amateurisy underscore x on
instagram and i don't genuinely i
genuinely don't have any closing
thoughts other than statistics are not
always right
okay
okay so my closing thoughts is when it
comes to relationship the highest form
of love is agape which is always a
sacrificial love and that's the love
that's going to give us fulfillment so
that's what we should focus on not on
our feelings but on the
the highest form of life which is icape
which is a sacrificial love
yeah you can find me on instagram on zed
lungu fitness
my closing thoughts are
one
if a man is high value enough whether or
not he's in a relationship he can
exercise his options if you guys were
with anthony joshua you'd let him cheat
twice a year
[Laughter]
the second one
is also as well
as as a community as
like as a nation
we need to start taking marriage
and dual parent households a lot more
seriously amen
yep um instagram the man called marty is
my username so final thoughts on this
i heard a lot of things that women had
to say that on that regard uh in that
sense and they feel like they will find
somebody in that regard and they may do
but the chances are from what we've
heard today
it is what it is you get what you get
and if you don't you're not going to get
that i mean they made a good case i'm
not going to lie we haven't learned a
lot of things today but it generally
feels like
it's not looking good
okay come on bro yo um
instagram d golly d double e g double l
where tick tock d golly with an extra y
on the end
my takeaway is that generally speaking i
think that when
these sorts of grievances against men
are aired i think that they're
really referring to
a significant minority but they're
expressed as if they refer to the
majority i think that in day initially
women ultimately pick the winners and i
think men learned that the easy way or
the hard way
all right i would like to say thank you
everyone for joining uh thank you
everyone for tuning in thank you
everyone that came
um
you shall see me uh next tuesday paul
okay guys you already know follow our
new facebook page follow our twitch page
and if you want to come on the show dm
our new recruiter eddie while you're at
it sign up for our memberships guys
memberships is what keeps the lights on
here views come and go but memberships
is what builds the community
on the second tier we have a new discord
we also have two bonus vlogs and at the
first tier the five dollar membership
you get to be a part of the chat
like the video that is so important to
pushing out these streams and the
algorithm subscribe to the channel
talk to you guys next time
take care guys
[Music]
and that's a wrap